And we're back,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by legal zoom
to start the new year correctly.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I believe it's a perfect time to get
your life organized,
organized,
organized.
How do you say Bryant?
Legal Zoom can help.
Legal Zoom is a way of dealing with very
common and standard legal issues that
you would ordinarily have to go to a
lawyer and make an appointment and spend
a lot of money.
You can get things done online for like
you can incorporate and form an llc
starting at $99.
You can protect your family with a last
will for $69 or get a living trust power
of attorney.
And the beautiful thing about legal zoom
is if you panic,
if you're in the middle of it and you're
like,
oh,
this is,
this can't be illegal,
this is fucked.
Legal Zoom will connect you with an
independent attorney and you.
The whole process can be easily sorted
out.
It can be.
They can help you with online support.
Their online process could not be much
easier.
They take care of you from start to
finish and now you get a special
discount from listening to the podcast.
Make sure you enter Rogan in the
referral box at checkout for more
savings and legal zoom.
They want you to know they're not a law
firm,
but they could connect you with a third
party attorney and provide you with self
help services.
The self help services is easy to do.
It is how on it was formed.
It is how Brian Form Desk squad.
You can do legal stuff online in a way
that was really,
really difficult to do in the past.
You had to know what the fuck you're
doing,
but now it's done for you.
And again,
if you panic,
legal zoom takes care of you.
So legalzoom.com.
Use the code word Rogan at checkout.
We are also brought to you by stamps.com
stamps.com is another awesome way to
deal with some tedious shit which is
going to the mail post office and giving
them the fucking boxes that you want to
send down and having them weigh and
measure each one of them.
And then all the nonsense you have to
deal with the weight and the line,
all the crap you could do all that at
home.
And with stamps.com,
you can print us postage right from your
desk using your own computer and printer
stamps.com.
Always update the postage rates for you
automatically.
It's really sweet.
And unlike those postage meter company
stamps.com,
never charges a fee to do it.
So it stamps.com.
You always get the exact postage you
need for any letter or package the
instant you need it.
We have a special offer for our podcast
listeners.
If you click on the old school
microphone in the upper right hand
corner and entering the word j r e,
you get a no risk trial and $110 bonus
offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to
$55 a free postage,
a digital scale that Brian dunning will
not use to weigh mushrooms on because he
knows that that's not right.
It's not nearly big enough.
It's not mad band.
Ladies and gentlemen,
go to stamps.com.
And before you do anything,
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage
and type in J R,
e Dot Brian uses it to send those tee
shirts from desk [inaudible] dot tv,
Tom,
Tom Segura and Christina [inaudible].
Use it for your mom's house for
Chrysler.
Uses it.
It is a very easy way to send postage
from your homes and postage.
Postage sent packages.
But again,
you measure it all yourself.
You do it all yourself.
Print it all yourself.
And then the postman picks it up and
you're done.
Sign.
Use The code word J.
R,
e dot.
And that's it.
Oh,
go to Ana.com,
blah,
blah.
You know that one.
Do you know that one already?
Go To r o n n I t,
use the covert Bergen.
Save yourself 10 percent off any and all
supplements,
blah,
blah.
Boom.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcasts all day.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Brian Denny.
Thank you sir.
Thanks for coming on.
The one of the cool things about the
internet is that you can get connected
to all these weird and unusual folks and
you can also exchange a lot of
information back and forth and find out
a lot of things about each other.
And,
uh,
I,
I read about,
you know,
nothing's coming.
This is fun friendly.
I read about you and uh,
I read some of the things that I didn't
know,
uh,
when you had contacted me that you had
included me in your.
How many celebrities were there?
Eight or 10.
It was a top 10.
Most wanted celebrities promoting
harmful pseudo science.
And in that I read about myself and I
was shocked to learn that I believe that
nine slash 11 was created by the
government.
I did not know.
I didn't know that.
I believe that.
I don't think you've ever said that.
I've never said that.
We can talk about the whole genesis of
how this list came to be.
Well,
that's a.
But that one is poorly researched.
I've absolutely never said that.
I think that the government engineered
nine slash 11.
Well,
this was an episode I did in 2008,
which was five,
six years ago now,
and so before coming here today,
I wanted to make sure and get all my
sources for all of these and
unfortunately back in 2008,
I was not yet keeping very good records
and saving my notes.
So for the things that I have listed
here,
unfortunately I can't give you the
source for any one of them,
but any one of them you want to tell him
he is not true.
I will happily retract it.
Well,
first of all,
the nine slash 11 one,
100 percent.
In fact,
I was on the phone with Alex Jones the
night that nine slash 11 happened.
The government engineer this documents,
they've been planning this since
operation northwoods.
I'm sure it didn't take him until that
night to figure it out.
He would probably.
Well I think he,
he actually might have even predicted
it,
but when you say that,
like people go,
Whoa,
is he a psychic?
He predicted a billion things that never
happened.
You know,
every day camps they've gotten coffins,
plastic,
coffins.
That doesn't mean that uh,
he was a clairvoyant.
It means he's,
he's a tightly,
tightly strong,
tightly wound up fella.
Oh,
do you think.
But uh,
I,
we debated it online on the air,
like,
you know,
I was like,
how do you,
you can't say that there's no evidence
that shows that the government did it
like you just because you suspect them
of doing it,
you can't say it.
There's also crazy shit that happens in
planes flying into buildings.
And I have a doctor,
not a real good doctor,
but he's a pot doctors.
Dr Hans you out a medical marijuana
prescriptions,
but I guess he went to medical school.
I go to them the other day and he hands
me this book and he's like,
uh,
this is very important information.
And I go,
okay.
So I start reading it and it's about
tesla technology that they use to make
the twin towers disappeared.
I got that.
The twin towers,
the reason why they turned into dust and
they just didn't fall apart into big
chunks is cars.
Tesla Tech.
I thought he was,
I thought it was like having like a,
like a mental issue.
Like I thought something had blown a
fuse or something.
I was so confused by the conversation.
I didn't know what he was saying.
Like you're saying they used unknown
technology to make the buildings
disappear.
How did you know them?
He's got a thick book.
You see the whole thing.
Tesla mythology is a whole other area
of,
of BS,
which is,
which is amazing.
So many of the things that Tesla is
known for never happened.
Um,
he was,
he was certainly a,
a very brilliant man.
Certainly a,
an innovative engineer,
but he didn't invent AC.
He didn't invent electric motors.
These are all things that already
existed that he continued working on.
He never invented a death ray.
He was completely nuts by the time of
his life.
He said he had a death ray.
He and Edison did have the competition
or the competing ideas about alternating
current and direct current.
And he was an advocate of alternating or
alternating current where Edison in fact
did tests to show or did displays or
other demonstrations to show that
dangers of this.
And one of the things they did is they
fried an elephant.
Yeah,
it's really fucked,
man.
If you watch it.
And he called it westing housing,
he called it.
We're going to westinghouse,
this elephant now.
He was hoping that that word would catch
on.
That's hilarious.
So,
um,
I don't know where you got the nine
slash 11 thing from a.
But if I had listened to me talk about
the moon landing,
I'd probably assume that I was also a
nonbeliever in nine slash 11.
So no,
never said that.
And it never believed that.
The only thing I've ever said that's
controversial at all is that tower
seven.
When you watch it fall,
it looks like in controlled demolition.
And I don't think that's controversial
because it looks like a controlled
demolition.
Yeah.
When you look at just the top half of
it,
it does.
When you look at the whole thing,
the way the way the structure,
correct.
There's no video,
the whole thing,
you can only see the video of the top.
Really the top quarter of it as it
disappears behind the building and I
agree it does look exactly like a
controlled demolition.
Oh,
I believe it's more than the top
quarter.
Pull the pull the video up of tower
seven dropping.
There's some pretty mean.
There's at least 30 floors.
You're seeing.
You're seeing a lot of it.
It's not really.
I wouldn't say it's the top quarter is a
48 for building.
I don't know.
I'm not gonna argue the fraction,
but you don't see the bottom of it was
true,
but it is very unusual how it falls into
its base instead of the falls over,
didn't
it felt it started to fall down
straight,
but then it almost destroyed two other
buildings that it fell against.
It didn't fall into its own foot.
Right.
Which any building that they were
demolishing would probably do as well if
they were that close to each other and
that went wrong.
Right.
Yeah.
We'll watch it again here.
Look at that.
Yeah.
That's way more than a tough quarter.
Okay.
It's not.
That's almost the entire building was
not.
Okay.
Let's see.
We'll see it again because we caught
that in the middle.
Let's see it again.
Let's see it from the top.
This is not the best angle of a bunch of
different angles.
Okay.
Let's say it again.
Pull that one back.
I mean it disappears into the smoke
before you can see,
but I think it's a bit disingenuous to
say that the thing doesn't fall into its
base.
Look at that.
It doesn't.
I mean it's already going at an angle.
Look at that.
Look at the k,
but it all fell to the bottom.
I mean,
let's look at that one.
Get her to fall to the top.
Okay,
but keep being kind of silly.
That thing collapsed into its space.
Look at that watch.
Here it goes.
That is most of the building vanishes
out of sight.
Who knows what happens from then on and
for sure it ran into other buildings.
The point is this,
it never happened before and it looks
like a controlled demolition.
I'm not saying,
but let me be clarified because this is
important.
I'm not saying it's a controlled
demolition.
I know I have no idea,
but that's what it looks like to say.
It doesn't look like that.
It's kind of silly.
No,
I agree,
but if you want to see how it fell into
its own base,
quote unquote,
just look at the aerial photographs that
were taken the next day when all the
smoke had cleared and you can see that
didn't remotely fall into its own base.
It fell down the street and just
practically destroyed two other
buildings so
well.
That's a matter of all that material has
to go somewhere.
You had 48 floors of material and all
comes down and collapsed.
It's going to fly.
I'm not saying it didn't fly to the
side.
It fell over.
It doesn't.
It didn't fall down and then out tube in
all directions like it splattered.
It fell over.
It started going down and then it went
to an angle and fell off to the side.
This is a really.
This is an interesting thing because
this is a thing that a lot of people
want the world to be very black and
white and they want things like this to
be really simple to categorize.
I don't think it is and I don't agree
with you that that didn't fall into its
base.
Sure.
A lot of other shit happened and
probably big chunks of it landed on
buildings nearby,
but that thing collapsed into its base.
Did it collapse into its base because of
a gigantic diesel fire that it consumed
the innards of the building and weaken
the structure considerably?
Fuck,
for sure.
That's possible.
I don't know a Goddamn thing about my
dad's an architect.
You know,
I asked him about it and he said,
well,
it's unusual,
but you don't know what the hell is
going on inside of it.
You don't know what kind of damage
sustained from having a building fall
out it.
You don't know what that diesel fuel
burning,
what it does.
This structure.
You don't know how they built the inside
of it.
Who knows?
It's weird,
but weird things happen when things
break.
That was his take on it,
but you can't say that that doesn't look
like a controlled demolition and I
didn't.
I said it does look like a controlled
demolition.
The bodies that you can see,
the most controversial thing I've ever
said about nine slash 11.
I've never said once that I think that
the government engineered it or that it
was.
I think it's very possible that big
events happen and then people capitalize
on those events and then things happen.
Like the invasion of Iraq.
They were probably looking for an excuse
do it anyway,
but the idea that it was all one big
grand scheme to me seems ridiculously
unlikely.
Okay.
Let me this,
this was actually a good segue into um,
what we started to talk about,
which was this,
this inclusion that I have your back in
this rise list of top celebrities
promoting pseudoscience.
Because what?
It's.
If someone had just listened to our last
five minutes here of the exchange,
it sounded like you were trying to
convince me that nine slash 11 was a
hoax to who were there.
Who would say that?
I think anyone who listens to that five
minutes,
it would sound like you were trying to
convince me.
Building seven was a demolition.
No,
it wouldn't.
Okay.
I was very specific that I don't think
it's grayer.
I don't think it's a black and white
issue.
I think it's a very gray area.
I think that that building looked like
it was demolished.
Was it demolished?
I absolutely don't know.
I'm too dumb.
I have zero education when it comes to
structural engineering zero education
when it comes to the damage that a fire
can do to a structure and caused it to
collapse and big chunks of buildings
hitting it.
What that can do,
I don't know,
but when I look at it,
it looks like a controlled demolition.
That does not sound like I'm trying to
convince you that nine slash 11 was a
hoax because I said very specifically
that I don't think it is,
and then I think that it's ridiculous to
assume that someone could be so
organized that they could talk these
guys into flying planes into buildings
and that they can make it,
that these buildings are rigged with
explosives secretly and some clandestine
operation with the banks and the NSA and
the dea and the CIA.
Everyone coordinating together so that
we could invade Iraq.
It sounds ridiculous
if you're a betting man.
If you had to bet yes or no.
Was nine slash 11 orchestrated by the
government?
If you had to bet,
would you bet on?
No,
not 100 percent,
but I will present that on them 100
percent,
but I know,
but
I wouldn't be surprised if two,
two additional possibilities.
One,
it was something that they knew possibly
could happen.
It didn't prevent against because either
of a and competence or b,
you have to look at things like
operation northwoods.
You have to look at the Gulf of Tonkin.
You have to look at real events that
took place,
meal plans,
that were questions.
Those are separate questions I would
say.
I would say there's always the
possibility that there was some
knowledge of it before,
but that.
But that's a separate question also.
Then they orchestrated it and caused it
to happen.
I do not have enough faith that the
government is so competent that they
could pull off this amazingly intricate
attack.
So if you're 100 percent,
if you're 100 percent betting,
no question.
So that means I might bet no,
but it doesn't mind that I'm asking for
your personal level of confidence,
your opinion and your personal.
If you're forcing me to bet,
then I would bet no,
I never say I know one way or the other.
So if I asked you what is your bet on
whether building seven was a controlled
demolition,
are you still 100 percent?
No,
I certainly wouldn't bet.
I certainly wouldn't bet because I don't
know enough.
But if I looked at it the way,
the way,
uh,
a person who's objective,
a person who understands what they know
and what they don't know in this life,
I would to say it
would be pretty fucking difficult to rig
a building with explosives and not have
anybody know about it.
It was pretty fucking difficult to make
that building implode and have it be
some sort of a secret that people kept.
It seems highly unlikely.
It seems more likely to me that there's
some sort of a catastrophic structural
failure.
But I would fucking sue the shit out of
those people that built that movie,
that,
that building rather.
If I was Larry,
what's his name that had a lateral
Silverstein,
I would sue the fuck out of the people
that built that building.
I was like,
look at this building.
Just fall down when it gets on fire like
you assholes.
I guess he got paid though from
insurance,
right?
He didn't need to do that.
If you didn't get that.
Part of the conspiracy is that money was
made off.
The conspiracy,
the words,
the wording,
pull it,
pull it out.
The fact that you said pull it,
it's my my take that anytime there's a
any sort of a catastrophic event,
whether it's a murder or an accident or
anything,
there's a bunch of people that look for
patterns in the chaos.
There's a bunch of people that look for
a following plot line and look for some
sort of nefarious connections between
people that would profit off this event
and just the randomness of of chaotic,
of being attacked,
of of death and about destruction.
I think it's more likely that it's more
likely that people are looking at this
and trying to make some sense out of it,
but this crazy chaotic event where
there's a bunch of suicide bombers,
flew planes into a building.
Things you know when?
When Neil Tyson was here.
How long ago was that?
Three,
four months ago.
Something like that.
It's about a year ago.
Okay.
He was.
He was making the point about how he
tries very much to give people the tools
to.
You can't teach everyone all the facts,
but you can give people the tools so
that they can probably figure out what's
true,
what's not true,
and he made some points about why that's
a valuable thing to have,
why it's good to have to be able to make
good decisions about the way the world
works and to understand the way things
really happen.
And it sounded to me like you've pretty
generally agreed with him.
Yes.
And I would too.
Um,
so in the case of this nine slash 11 as
a,
as an example,
I mean we've got 100 different
conspiracy theories here,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And not even conspiracy theories,
but just playing up pseudosciences it
makes just,
it makes sense to help people to come to
the right conclusion to come to a
conclusion.
That's probably true because that's
symptomatic of all the other areas in
their life where they're going to have
to consider issues and make up a good
informed opinion.
That's probably more likely to be true.
Wouldn't you agree with that?
I mean,
that's really the same thing he's
saying.
So if it then makes sense for you to to
to promote the idea that nine slash 11
was probably not a government
conspiracy,
then why would you spend five minutes
showing me this video and bringing it to
the,
to,
to the attention of everyone on your
show saying,
hey,
look at this.
Look how it was probably a controlled
demolition look.
I'm sorry.
Look how much it looked like a
controlled demolition because it does.
Because it's interesting.
Yeah,
but unless you're framing that within
the context of look
how easy it is to be mistaken,
which is not what you said,
but why?
Why?
Why do I have to do that?
And to just observe something that's
fascinating.
You don't have to do it,
but what Neil was Tyson was trying to
sell you on was the value of doing it.
Help.
Giving people the tools to understand
the way the world probably actually
work.
How does that relate to you?
Listening to me go on about how it looks
like a controlled demolition.
You agree that it looks like a
controlled demolition and just because
I'm expressing that,
you're saying that if someone listened
to that,
they think they would think rather than,
I'm trying to convince you that nine
slash 11 was a hoax.
I think that's a giant stretch.
It I,
I think that's what it sounded like.
I think sound like that.
To me,
the most rational objective people
listening,
they would have heard all the caveats
that I threw in there all the times that
I said,
now I don't believe this.
I don't,
but looking at that and watching it
collapse like that,
it looks like a controlled demolition.
I think you'd be a fool to disagree.
It looks exactly like that.
Is it one?
That's not what I'm saying.
I don't know.
I've said very clearly.
I know nothing about architecture
architecture.
I know nothing about engineering.
I know nothing about the impact of
diesel fire on concrete and steel.
I don't know.
Okay.
Well,
let me go back again to how this is a
good segue to what I wrote back in 2000,
which hopefully the end result of me
being here today will be.
I will get back to all my listeners and
say,
I'm retracting your appearance on this
list.
Okay,
so just a paragraph.
You know.
Okay.
If I read this short,
so I think you were a number eight on my
list of top 10 celebrities who promote
harmful pseudoscience,
and here's the paragraph that I wrote on
you.
Number eight,
Joe Rogan,
comedian Joe Rogan does what he can to
promote virtually any conspiracy theory
that he stumbles onto apparently
accepting them all uncritically where
they wholesale embrace.
Now,
I know you would disagree with that.
of course it would and I want to give
you that chance so I'm me.
Continue.
He believes the Apollo astronauts did
not land on the moon.
He believes the US government was behind
the nine slash 11 terrorist attacks.
He believes the Oliver Stone version of
the Kennedy assassination.
He believes aliens crashed at Roswell in
1947 and the government is covering it
up.
He thinks men and black from project
blue book stole his friend's camera even
though project blue book ended over 38
years ago.
My friend was tanny 60,
by the way.
I didn't steal his Canada,
what to hear that story,
but they took it when he was a little
boy.
He took a photo of something.
Who knows what it was.
I never said it was project blue book
guys,
are they?
I told you what?
My friend who was a flight surgeon told
me I wish to hell I had that.
I had the reference for that,
but let me just fits.
Okay,
well that's part of the call Steve and
get them on the phone.
Steve Graham.
That'd be fun.
Actually,
the worst part is that he promotes these
ideas to the public at every interview
opportunity,
but gives himself the intellectual get
out of jail free card of not needing any
evidence by hiding behind the childish
debate technique of saying,
Hey,
I'm just the guy asking questions.
God,
this makes me sound like an asshole.
Well,
it's just factually inaccurate on so
many different levels.
I don't
understand why you wrote it like that,
like there's things that you said that I
believe that I don't,
that I've never said that I do.
What I'm willing to do is look stupid
and by talking about things and saying
that looks like a controlled demolition.
I know that puts you in the the nutter
camp,
but I'm not saying it's a controlled
demolition,
but I say that not being willing to
debate it and being insecure to discuss
it rather not debate it,
but to discuss the reality of what
you're viewing is silly.
It's preposterous.
It doesn't mean I'm promoting the idea
that nine slash 11 was an inside job or
that it was a plot by the government.
I don't think that.
I've never thought that,
but I do think that building looks like
a controlled demolition.
That's all.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with saying that.
I think.
I think at the time that I did this,
I think you had.
It was shortly after when you went on
Penn Jillette's radio show and talked
with Phil plait about the moon.
Remember that?
Sure.
And you kicked his butt.
Well,
unfortunately,
look,
I would not have handled that the way I
handle it then today,
but there's two unfortunates.
One was that I really wanted him when we
first went on to give me a reason to not
believe what this Fox documentary showed
me,
but the more I talked to him,
the more I realized that he was almost
like talking in in a religious sense in
that he wasn't willing to criticize any
aspect of,
of NASA or any aspect of what was going
on during that time,
including the point where he was trying
to deny the fact that Werner Herzog or
Wernher von Braun rather,
and many other scientists were actually
Nazis that would come over and operation
paperclip and he's like,
you know,
he's trying to deny that there were
Nazis.
I'm like,
well,
this is crazy.
Like you're trying to deny historical
fat because you think that historical
fact shades NASA in a bad way,
and I don't think it does.
I think the NASA of 1969 or [inaudible]
63 when Kennedy was in office is not the
NASA of 2013 or 14.
These.
These people are long dead and gone,
and to deny that there was a bunch of
Nazis involved.
Seems to me that's not healthy.
It seems to me like it's fucking with
the facts and it doesn't support your
argument.
In fact,
it makes me question all the other
stuff,
so then I started getting aggressive
with them because I'm like,
well,
you're being silly because this isn't.
You're not.
You're not being honest about the Nazis.
You're not being honest about this
connection.
Okay,
well I got to throw that back at you.
What the hell does,
whether they're not twos or not have
anything to do with whether we went to
the moon?
Well,
it doesn't,
but denying the fact that there were
Nazis has something to do with what kind
of information I'm getting from him.
I'm not getting unbiased information.
Well,
I don't remember.
I don't remember that part of the
conversation,
but I remember that Wernher von Braun
had gone to Antarctica to pick,
to collect rocks to collect meteors and
you brought that up and I think you said
words to the effect of why the heck
would he have done that?
Unless it was part of some grander
scheme to fake bringing rocks back from
the mood.
Am I correct about that?
I said,
well,
I said Wernher von Braun did go to
Antarctica.
You did.
When they were preparing for the moon
landing,
and Phil Phil had no idea.
In fact,
I think he said he had never even heard
that fact when I was a lot of photos
online of Wernher von Braun and this big
crew.
There was one of the few places where
they could go.
They could study meteors that were
definitely from the moon.
Right,
and fill it,
fill.
It,
fills an astronomer.
He's not a space historian.
I understand.
He would have no reason to know that,
but why?
Why were you bringing that up?
What does that have to do with the
question?
Well,
the big conspiracy was of course that he
had brought these rocks back from there,
and then somehow or another,
those were the ones that they forged for
the moon rocks.
When they talked about where'd they get
these rocks from the moon?
Well,
there's absolutely meteors that came
from the moon that are in Antarctica.
You can find them,
they can retrieve them.
They've documented that so that the idea
is that you have a chunk of the moon.
Here's,
here's the rocks we brought back from
the moon.
We want to know what to look for.
We want to know what their,
what kind of mass they've got,
things like that to how to,
how to make room for them in the
spaceship.
Yeah.
What they're made out of,
what their contents are,
and as an alternative that could be seen
as being consistent with the moon
landing was exactly,
exactly.
What would you call it?
Evidence or would you call it consistent
with.
Or would you say those are the same
thing?
I wouldn't say it's evidence.
I mean,
look,
all you.
Let's say that they could land on the
moon.
Okay.
Let's say,
which by the way,
I believe now and let's say that,
uh,
they took spaceships and they went there
and they brought back moon rocks.
I think if you knew for sure that there
were some moon rocks in Antarctica,
you would absolutely go there and study
them.
I don't think it's a bad thing,
but I do think that if you're a guy
looking for something that confirms your
suspicions of a of a conspiracy,
which I was,
I would say,
well look,
they went to get moon rocks and that's
[inaudible].
That's the big thing.
They always say they brought back x
kilograms of moon rocks where they get
those.
They went to Antarctica,
they got them from the Antarctica.
And look,
here's a photo of Warner von Braun in
Antarctica collecting moon rocks with a
fucking cast on his arm for some strange
reason.
How'd he break his arm?
Do you know?
I,
I didn't know that he had some old
school cast to mad.
Some fucking funky cartoon casts with
like a bar between them.
He must've really jacked his arm,
but they probably broke his arm to get
him to lie about going to the moon.
See,
I've got it all locked up.
Yeah.
Look,
I,
like I said,
I wouldn't have,
I wasn't podcasting then.
And uh,
I certainly wasn't watching as many
documentaries and reading these many
books.
I wasn't.
I was in the middle of doing fear factor
in working for the UFC and I'd watched
this documentary on the Fox,
the Fox documentary on a conspiracy
theory.
Did we really go to the moon and it was
incredibly compelling,
especially if you're a retard like me
and you're watching Brian O'leary,
who was an astronaut saying that he
could see that they could fake it and
you're watching bill casing.
It was the guy who worked at Rocketdyne
and he said that the engineers all agree
that no one could do this,
and then you look at the different
backgrounds that they showed in
different trips and they were basically
the same background,
but they were nowhere near each other.
They had done it.
They've done a really good job of
piecing together all this weirdness and
then do it with a narrator and spell it
out for you and I bought it.
Hook,
line,
and sinker for sure.
The the real issue.
There's a bunch of real issues with
faking the moon lane.
Of course,
the numbers of people that would be
involved,
the amount of technology that you would
have to discount where people could
track lunar module as it went in the
lineage of creating the Saturn five and
how they see the stages of detached and
all the different mathematical
calculations they did create them,
but if you break it down to an hour
documentary for a dummy and you put some
spooky music in it and you keep cutting
back and forth to commercials,
you're going to believe that we didn't
go to the moon.
Yeah,
it's the easiest ID in the world to
sell.
Conspiracy theories are so just people
want to believe them.
They satisfy so much.
They're fun to fund.
It makes you feel like you've got some
secret insider information,
but there's also.
There was evidence that
NASA did fake some publicity shots.
They did from the Gemini Program,
Michael Collins,
they used a photo of him where he was in
a simulator and they used it and they
blacked it out and had the exact same
image and released it as a press photo.
So what is this deception?
Does that mean that there was deception
across the board?
No,
but I did this Saifai show and in the
middle of the Scifi show,
someone who is an editor took some
footage and spliced in some sound and
faked something and said that a user
centered in not to my knowledge and I
found out about it and freaked out and I
said,
well,
when you fake one thing,
like we,
we spent this entire show trying to
figure out the truth about something and
you guys for dramatic effect faked one
thing,
you fucked up the whole show because
what you did is you cast doubt on
everything else this show is ever going
to say ever.
Like literally hast almost die right
here because you're the ethic of
creating a completely honest show has
already been gone.
It's already been washed away.
And when you watch something like the
moon landing and you know,
you look at the,
these guys hopping around on the moon,
you kind of almost want it to be
bullshit.
Kind of like what they fuck.
They got to.
Come on man.
How the fuck you look up at the moon?
Have Fuck,
are they getting up there and then you
find shit like this where they show
these images of,
you know,
Michael Collins in the simulator and
then the exact image all blacked out
background saying that he's actually in
space like,
oh,
he's in Spain.
Who's taken this picture of him in space
like this?
He's not in space.
This is the same image.
Like you guys lied.
So because of that,
NASA is,
they're not perfect.
They weren't perfect in the fact that
they hired a bunch of Nazis and brought
them over from,
from Germany.
They weren't perfect in the fact that,
you know,
I'm sure some people in the publicity
department told some tall tales and spun
some yarns and you know,
they had a makeup for Gus Grisham dying
in that simulator.
There's a lot of like horrible
publicity,
snafoos terrible things that went wrong
that eroded people's confidence in,
in NASA.
I could easily see a fake here or there
a photograph that was that was
staged here or there that they said
happened on the moon or that they said
happened in space.
I don't think that that means
necessarily that the moon landing was
faked though then I did.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's pretty common piece of feedback
that I'll get when
I do an episode on any,
any given conspiracy theory and let's
say it's one like this that involves the
government.
The,
the feedback that I'll get is so you
believe the government loves us and is
perfect and everything they do,
it's like,
oh,
it's not necessary for NASA to be
perfect for us to have gone to the moon.
It's not necessary for the government to
be perfect for nine slash 11,
not to have been an incense.
The classic Straw man.
Black and white argument.
Yeah.
No,
it's.
You're either and that's exactly what I
said about the building collapsing.
It's basically the same thing.
It's not.
It doesn't mean that the government is
beautiful and perfect in every way
because they managed to go to the bone.
Agreed.
Yeah.
So should we go through this checklist
here?
Which of these I can take off?
Yeah.
What was,
what was the other one?
You had another one that I.
let's start with a violently disagreed
with it.
Was was the first one.
Oh,
fascination.
Okay.
He believes the Apollo astronauts didn't
land on the moon.
That's gone.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's good.
I'm checking it off.
I would love it if it was a hoax style.
If I found out that it was a hoax,
I got to tell you right now.
I would love it almost more than I love
the fact that people went to the moon.
I would love it if it was a hoax.
Capricorn won.
Best movie ever.
No,
it wasn't.
It wasn't even close.
It was a good movie,
but alien was the best movie.
Alien one,
the first one in my opinion,
and it had,
it had the evil corporate government
conspiracy behind it.
Um,
I do not believe in knowledge over
stones,
in fact,
have criticized that film on this
podcast many times because Oliver stone
created in the Donald Sutherland
character.
They can use this vehicle for this
general that's giving him this
information in order to spell it all out
to the Kevin Costner character.
I've never said that.
You know what I've said.
I said,
if you look at that bullet,
it doesn't look like went through
people.
That's what I've said,
because if you look at the single
bullet,
it does not look like it penetrated
bone.
See that bones are.
You see that Scott?
I'm a hunter.
I'm an actual bonafide hunter.
I know what it looks like when bullets
hit meet and that that bullet does not
look like it went through to people.
Did you beat the fuck out of that thing?
Nice to save any.
I have some.
I'll get you some you like.
Do you like venison?
I love it.
I just got one in Wisconsin last month.
Relatives in Oregon.
They're sending us stuff all the time.
The best meat.
It's so delicious and so healthy and I
like the fact that it's wild.
It's running around wild and then you
take it out of the mix,
but I've never said that Oliver Stone
was right.
In fact,
I've said there was A.
I liked the movie,
I think Kevin Costner and knocked it out
of the park.
I think it was an interesting movie,
but what I've like about it is that it
opens up this idea where people start to
question what happened.
Okay.
I,
I think what I,
what I meant by that statement was you.
You don't believe that Lee Harvey Oswald
acted alone.
I do not believe Lee Harvey Oswald acted
alone.
No,
I think there's ample evidence that
there was other people involved,
but that doesn't mean that Lee Harvey
Oswald wasn't involved.
There's another black or white thing.
Everybody wants an either or.
I think it's very possible that Lee
Harvey Oswald was in cahoots with that
murder.
First of all,
Lee Harvey Oswald was on the scene.
Second of all,
Lee Harvey Oswald was known to be in bed
with all these fucking Weirdo characters
he had brought.
He had gone Russia and
brought back a woman and was allowed to
reenter the United States.
The fact that Jack Ruby got to Lee
Harvey Oswald and the really high
pressure situation,
she shot the fucking president and you
just have them wandering through with
this gangster can run up to them and put
a bullet in him.
It plays out like a movie,
so in fact,
so you've got a lot of anomalies that
are consistent with any conspiracy,
conspiracy and but my take on it is not
that I know or that I believe in Oliver
Stone.
My take on it is what a colossal strange
event,
a changing of us history,
a changing of the way we look at the
power of being a president,
a changing of the way we look at what
can happen to someone in this lifetime.
When someone who is so beloved as John F
Kennedy disappears off the face of the
earth and the world instantaneously
changes.
I think it's a fascinating story and I
also think it's fascinating how many
enemies he had.
You can't discount when you're talking
about people who were involved with
people who have created wars,
people who have absolutely been
responsible for the death of untold
thousands of people.
You can't discount the idea that they
would organize a coup.
I don't know if they did,
but I do know that that thing was one
colossal clusterfuck,
a crazy thing,
and that the fact that the film was held
back until her Waldo Rivera of all
people put it on television with Dick
Gregory who bought a lot of people,
don't even realize is a great comedian,
was a great comedian and an activist at
the time.
And it was way into the seventies that
Dick Gregory played this on Geraldo
Rivera show.
And you get to see Kennedy's head
snapped back.
And this router film.
I don't think that that means that
someone else did it.
I think it means there's probably more
than one person involved.
And when you look at the Warren
Commission report and you look at the
inconsistency is in it.
There's a great book about it called the
best evidence by David Lifton,
who was,
um,
he was actually an accountant and was
hired to go over the Warren Commission
report and found inconsistency after
inconsistency over and over again,
and detailed these in great order.
But the difference in the inconsistency
of the autopsies and consistencies of
the various reports of what went down in
consistencies in the Warren Commission
of their findings that would cancel out
each other's findings.
He was one of the few guys were the
first guys to go through the entire 900
volumes.
Fascinating.
Fascinating book that I read when I was
living in New Jersey.
I was living in New York rather,
and it was doing a Gig on the road and I
read it and fucking bombed that night.
Oh my God.
It was in my hotel room all day reading
is freaky conspiracy books.
Shit in my pants and I was like 23 years
old.
And then I went on stage that night and
just had terrible and I learned a very
valuable lesson from that book.
Don't read or watch depressing shit
right before you go onstage or break
into big conspiracy mongering in the
middle of your set that you just know.
Nobody came to conspiracy freak for sure
for sure.
That book best evidence was what threw
me over the top.
Well,
you know,
I did an episode on,
on,
on
the JFK assassination a about a month or
two ago and I'd been putting it off for
years because there is so much,
so much bs and so much real information
on that.
Then I found this is,
this is impossible.
How am I going to distill this into a 12
minute show because my son was 12
minutes,
12 minutes long every week.
That's insane.
You need to spread out.
Yeah.
So what,
what,
um,
what I decided to do is not to address
any of the conspiracy theories,
but just talk about why in general,
the conspiracy theories
individual and myriad as they are,
why they don't stand up to,
you know,
what's,
what we,
um,
unfortunately called the official story
quote unquote,
kind of a weasel word.
Um,
and it really,
the thing is that what all conspiracy
theories have in common is that they are
united only in that they dispute the
official story.
For example,
you can say the,
the Cubans Killed Kennedy,
or you can say the Russians killed
Kennedy.
Or you can say the mob killed Kennedy.
Or you can say the secret service men
running alongside,
accidentally shot him,
whatever.
And all the people who promote those
conspiracies,
they,
they consider themselves united as a
group even though their theories are
absolutely factually exclusive of one
another.
Almost like competing religions.
They.
Yeah,
exactly.
They,
they cannot possibly be,
be brought together.
The only thing they have in common is
that they simply say the government's
lying.
And as long as you say the government's
lying than hey,
you're,
you're okay.
You're in the club.
Your theories.
All right?
Your theory is more likely that that's
the government to find out.
We're talking about this.
It's,
it's happened.
It's happened.
You right?
You know Vince Bugliosi his book.
I didn't like it.
What was it called?
Case closed case or whatever.
Okay.
Was called case closed.
He talked about,
I can't remember what it was called,
so I'll accept that in us.
We don't have to accept anything.
This is google.
He talked about one.
One person that he interviewed who
believed posner too.
Sterile pose.
Nurse case closed.
Okay.
He believes one person he interviewed,
um,
believed that Kennedy was still alive
and likely and that he had committed
suicide.
Uh,
yes.
I heard the,
the secret service man shot him.
I heard A.
I heard like you could see him shoot him
on the,
on the video for that.
Okay.
The driver shot him.
Yeah.
The driver turned around.
So even,
even having,
even even one person having their own
belief that is self contradictory seems
more likely than believing what the
government says and the government
obviously is not perfect,
but you can't.
You cannot say that just because the
government agrees with one particular
version of events that that event is
therefore wrong.
You're right.
And that's a huge,
hugely popular argument that I get
reclaiming history.
Fascinating.
I didn't read this.
I read the other one.
You're right.
However,
it doesn't disclude the possibility that
there was in fact some sort of a
conspiracy.
No,
it certainly doesn't,
but the fact that the,
that the government found one version of
the events more compelling and wrote
their official version on that doesn't
make that version of wrong.
You're right.
And that's the hardest.
That's the hardest point to communicate
to the people who believe that it
certainly doesn't.
The inconsistencies that are troubling
in the Warren commissions are part are.
There's several,
but one of the big ones is the single
bullet theory or the need for the single
bullet theory.
The reason why they needed to formulate
the single bullet theory is because they
had an account for three shots.
They had a new bullet that it hit
ricocheted against the curbs,
term kerbstone on under the overpass,
and a guy had gotten hit by the
ricochet,
so he was in the hospital and they had
seen the mark on the curb stone,
so they attributed that to a bullet.
So they say,
okay,
well we know for sure someone was
shooting from the direction the school
book depository.
That's one thing.
Then that confirmed actually supporting
the idea that Oswaldo did it or that
someone in Oswald's position did it.
So bullet did come from there,
but now they had to account for all
these wounds and so how did they do
that?
Well,
instead of saying,
well,
maybe there was more than one bullet,
maybe there was more than three shots.
Maybe there was more than two people
shooting.
They had to come up with some sort of a
reason why one bullet could do all this
damage.
That to me seems a much less likely
scenario.
Then there's more than one shooter.
The more than one shooter.
If you're going to kill the fucking
president and if there is a conspiracy
and we haven't proven that there's not
more that there is,
but if there's going to be a conspiracy,
I would doubt you would give it to one
guy named Lee Harvey Oswald,
one guy and give them a rifle that's not
even that fucking good and put them in a
window and given this crazy shot that
most people are not going to make.
That's not a good shot.
If you've ever shot at something.
Moving targets are incredibly difficult
and moving targets.
When you're.
You have this shitty bolt action rifle
and you got to reload it.
It's a long time to do that.
You can get it off if you.
I mean,
I've seen the people that have pulled it
off in a test where they've said try to
reproduce it and they can do it.
You can get those shots off and you can
do,
but you're not going to be accurate.
You need a couple of seconds to be
accurate.
You need your fucking shooting the
president.
This is not some low pressure situation.
This is the first person you've ever
assassinated with a rifle.
My position is that it's more likely
that they had a predetermined outcome
that they were trying to reach that
outcome is that they wanted to tie up
everything with Lee Harvey Oswald and
one of the best ways to do that.
It's an attribute all these different
wounds to one bullet.
Does it mean that all those wounds were
not created by one bullet?
No,
because it's one of the weird things
that happens when you shoot things.
Things hit bone and they ricochet and
they go weird directions and strange
anomalies happen to bullets where a
bullet will kill someone and you'll look
at it.
It looks like it's virtually
undisturbed.
Every now and then shit gets weird,
but for the most part when a bullet goes
through to people and shatters bone and
both of them,
especially the risk of connolly on the,
on the end of it,
and then winds up in the Gurney in this
pristine form like the single bullet
theory did when they found that bullet.
That's unlikely.
I've got A.
I've got a 50 caliber round that that we
found in death valley leftover from the
days when they would do fighter planes
just shooting their machine guns over
from China Lake and what what it.
What it is is I'm a completely
flattened,
smudged,
irreconcilable piece of copper and
protruding out from the center of it is
this absolutely pristine tungsten
missile that looks like it's fresh from
the factory,
absolutely sharp,
completely undamaged,
and it's inside this copper jacket that
is.
That's been peeled what?
Peeled away from it and completely
smashed out to to unrecognizable.
It's real effect.
When I found it,
we're looking at going,
what the heck is this?
Is this a bullet that somebody shot into
something and it's still hanging on?
Yeah,
so I understand what a really,
really weird stuff can go on with
bullets.
Weird stuff can go on with bullets.
One of my favorite paper,
so I have to talk about it.
Yeah,
I'm a,
I'm really getting into ballistics
lately.
I've been doing a lot of target shooting
and talking to a.
I have a very good friend,
my friend Justin who is a,
a complete gun nut and if I have any
questions about ballistics and,
and things,
I will talk to him about it.
And uh,
you know,
he'll tell you like weird shit happens
sometimes you shoot a person and the
bullet will come back at you through
there.
I like,
that's happened to guys like guys and
special forces.
They've assassinated somebody or killed
somebody and the bullet hits bone and
somehow or another figures out a way to
pop out of their eye,
like slides around the inside of the.
Somebody's trying other somehow or
another ricochets in.
Well there's,
you know,
there's random weird shit that can
happen when you shoot people.
So is it possible that a bullet went to
Kennedy and then went into connolly?
Yeah.
One hundred percent weird shit happens,
but does it look like that bullet did
that?
Not at all.
No.
It looks like that bullet.
They fired into a tank of water.
That bullet doesn't look like it hit
anything because it's a lead bullet
that's jacketed and the jacket isn't
bent.
It's not disturbed.
And to my knowledge,
people have tried to recreate that.
I know Penn and teller tried to do it.
I think miss mythbusters tried to do it.
They weren't able to do it.
When they hit bone,
they were only able to do.
If they pass just through the flesh,
you can pass through flash and leave a
bullet relatively undisturbed,
but if you hit bone and you shatter that
bone,
most likely you're making a mess out of
that bullet.
Didn't they find pieces in the body
also?
Absolutely.
In pieces in Connolly's wrist that did
not match what was missing from the
bullet.
There was more pieces in connally's
body.
Then we're missing from the bullet.
Does that mean that he didn't get hit
with some,
you know,
random shrapnel and bullets are fucking
flying and weird shit happens and you
know,
there's a lot of weird shit that goes on
when you're in a gunfight,
but I think you would probably have to
attribute that to more than three
bullets.
Aliens in Roswell never said that.
In fact,
have a joke goofing on it on my,
on my comedy special from 1999 where I
say that,
uh,
that people say the government actually
printed in the paper.
They have recovered a crashed Ufo and
alien bodies and the next day they made
a mistake up.
Sorry.
It was just a weather balloon.
Like,
well,
what about the aliens?
Those are Mexicans.
Apparently they were on the balloon.
They were drinking,
some shenanigans took place.
They mistook the balloon for opinion.
It's very tragic.
You know,
I never said that.
I think that what I did say that is
absolutely fascinating and fun thing to
think about.
The fact that they could have found some
crashed ufo from another planet and
hushed everybody up and hit these bodies
and little child's coffins run away with
them,
but everybody that I've talked to that
has ever told me a story about being
abducted by Ufos are taken aboard a
craft or any of their fucking crazy.
That's the one thing they all share.
They all share this nutty disconnect
with reality.
I've talked to people that have told me
some weird things about animals.
I talked to a woman that was very
convincing that told me she had a
bigfoot sighting,
very convincing,
less shroud.
Who's the survivor man told me some
animal was by beetles running through
the woods and that,
but as far as you iphones,
I'm still waiting for the one guy who
tells me anything that makes sense.
I got in a hundred arguments with people
when I was filming the Scifi show that
were believers.
When I was asking them for evidence.
I was like,
well,
where's the evidence?
Like we have sworn affidavits.
I go,
that's not evidence.
he goes,
that is evidence.
That's evidence in a court of law.
You can convict people for murder unless
I go,
that's not scientific evidence like,
Oh,
you have a story.
That's all you have is a story.
Nobody wants there to be aliens more
than me,
but all I see when I go looking for
aliens is a bunch of unfuckable white
dudes with stories about spaceships and
flying saucers and all sorts of things
that make their regular,
mundane,
boring life seem insignificant because
of this greater threat,
greater mystery,
greater enigma,
this huge thing that's going on where we
being observed by aliens.
It adds this excitement to an otherwise
mundane life.
And does that mean that there are no
aliens?
Absolutely not.
Does it mean that aliens aren't
observing us?
Absolutely not,
but it does mean is that the consistency
that I've found in talking to people
that claimed to vet alien experiences
make me think that the aliens are so
intelligent that they only picked
dummies.
They're so intelligent that they pick
people that were easily discounted.
So you listened to their stories and go,
go ahead.
Tell somebody who the fuck is going to
believe you.
You're crazy.
So they find people that have a problem
with the truth and then abduct them.
That's,
that's the only thing that makes sense.
How would you call your.
Would you describe yourself as a science
advocate?
One hundred percent?
Yes.
I'm a huge fan of science.
It's one of the things that I forgot to
argue with Stefan Molyneux when he was
on the podcast recently.
Not argued,
but he argues against funding,
scientific research and space
exploration.
And to me it is,
it fuels my day if I get up in the
morning and I read about some new thing
that they're doing where,
I mean even I've been following this
idea of putting a man mission on Mars
and these people that are going to have
to go there on is one way trip and my
fucking hands sweat just thinking about
it.
Those things fuel my day.
I'm by science,
absolutely fascinated by science.
I the,
the thing that I love,
um,
uh,
doing,
doing the scaphoid episodes,
my favorite part of it is solving the
mysteries that people usually leave
unsolved because they stop at the
paranormal explanation.
For example,
the whole Williamson Roswell,
take that as an example.
If you take the national enquirer
version of events,
it's sensational and it's fun.
Aliens are here,
aliens or visiting us,
the government's coming here,
but it's got all of that,
all the compelling qualities of a story
that we love,
but the fact is that those people
haven't solved the mystery and what I
enjoy most is completing the process,
going all the way through it actually,
you know,
actually finding the pot of gold at the
end of the rainbow.
Actually finding the solution to what
happened
whenever possible,
well isn't what makes it exciting to
these people that you never really can
do that unless you can get a time
machine and go back to Roswell,
New Mexico in 1940.
What is it?
Seven?
Was it seven,
nine,
47 years?
I have the actual front page of the
Roswell daily record on my home framed.
Oh,
do you?
Very cool.
It's fascinating.
What's also fascinating historically,
just to look at all the other things
that were in the news that were stories
and try to picture yourself living at
this time,
and I'll 70 years ago.
It's weird 77 years ago,
but the other thing that's weird about
it is that you can't go back so you
can't know.
You got a bunch of different people and
some of them tell you they saw aliens.
Someone tell you to say bodies and Max
Roswell's,
Maxwell,
Brazel,
whatever the fuck his name was,
swingers and all these different people.
And then you'd see the press conference
where they have this to look.
It's just this stuff,
you know,
it's so delicious to think in terms of
conspiracy to think in terms that the
government has this unbelievable magical
information that they're not sharing
with us because they don't think that we
can handle it and it becomes this thing
that makes every average everyday life
more exciting.
And in on that same vein in the question
of going all the way back to building
seven,
for example.
Um,
to me,
let's say,
I don't think it is an open question,
but let's say the open question of
whether it was a,
a,
a government conspiracy or not,
let's say we're just going to leave that
unsettled.
Okay.
We don't know,
maybe,
maybe it was,
maybe it wasn't,
but to me what's really interesting
about that is the underlying science is
how would a building made of steel and
covered with concrete or whatever it was
made of,
how would that melt,
why would it collapse and understanding
the actual scientists to me,
far more interesting than simply doing
this anomaly hunting that,
that is so much more popular and trying
to point fingers and turn it into a
whole political,
ideological thing.
Absolutely.
What is your background?
What is your education?
And uh,
my,
my back,
my background is in computer science
and,
but uh,
I,
I never,
I never really worked in the field.
I was um,
um,
I did software consulting basically for
most of my career until I became a
science writer about the six,
seven years ago.
How would you feel if someone with no
software knowledge whatsoever started
criticizing software development that
you were involved with?
If they were,
say like an architect?
Since I was always really bad at it.
I
know I would say just as you expect,
I'd say,
well,
I probably know better than you do right
now.
When you see architects and engineers
for nine slash 11 truth.
When you see this group of people,
how many architects are involved?
Brian Google that shit.
Architects and engineers from nine slash
seven.
Truth.
There's a substantial number of people,
but unfortunately it's something of the
people who actually are in that field
and most of them are not.
Um,
it's a tiny fraction of a percentage of
all the people who work in that period
overall.
Right?
So if you're trying to look at what most
architects and engineers say,
overwhelmingly,
they have no problem with quote unquote
theater,
honestly,
that it's been studied by most
architects and engineers.
And again,
just for the record,
again,
I'm not,
I don't believe in a conspiracy to for
nine slash 11.
I never have.
But I'm saying that,
you know,
this is kind of throws in the face of
what you said,
like these are educated people,
they were trained as architects and
engineers and they have this,
this issue with building 72,000,
134 architects and engineers.
That's kind of a lot.
I will say this,
the people who have spent the most time
on the question are overwhelmingly
believers in the conspiracy of course,
but whereas the causal relationship
there,
it's not that they spent most time
learned the most information and then
made a rational decision based on what
they learned.
It's the other way around.
They spend time obsessing with it
because they were ideologically married
to the idea from the very beginning.
If you say that that dismisses them and
that's a good thing to say if you try to
dismiss them,
but I don't think you know them and I
don't think you've really examine why
they came to these conclusions or why
they were interested in interested in
investigating it in the first place.
Well,
this is what I do for a living is I talk
to the stand.
I understand that,
but what I'm saying is I know you didn't
interview 2000 people.
He didn't ask all those different guys,
so the say that in a blanket general
statement that this is the reason why
they came to this conspiracy is a little
disengaged.
He was absolutely.
Generalizations are always wrong.
I think that's a real issue and I think
that's what we're dealing with here.
Where you had this reluctance to accept
the fact that I wasn't saying that nine
slash 11 was an inside job just because
I was saying tower seven looks like a
demolition.
It's the same thing.
Like if I listened to this,
I would think that you're trying to
convince it.
No,
no,
it's not.
It's not a black and white issue.
There's a lot of weirdness.
There's a lot of weirdness in the world
and there's a lot of weirdness and
perception.
There's a lot of weirdness in people
that are educated but are also
incorrect.
It's a common thing.
It happens all the time and you're
absolutely correct at 2000 people out of
what number of vast number of architects
and engineers there exists in the world,
but the real question is how many of
those other people that exist have
examined this as thoroughly as these
people and you're right,
the ones that would examine it,
the ones who are looking to find some
sort of conspiracy,
does that mean they're wrong?
Well,
in this case,
you and I both believe that they're
wrong,
but that doesn't mean they're wrong.
Well,
there's.
There's not a lot of people
realistically who work in the field of
failure analysis for building structure,
but those who do,
my guess is,
and people can call in and tell me I'm
wrong.
Shouldn't no one can call in.
We shouldn't.
That's not good.
That's my,
my.
My supposition is that is that the
people who work in building analysis,
failure analysis of buildings had no
problem with what they saw happening on
telly.
I wouldn't guess that that's going to go
on Jesus.
They didn't need to.
Well,
because I mean it's,
it's clear if you just watch any
documentary on the,
on how the structure collapsed.
Well,
if those people that
believe in the engineers and architects
for nine slash 11 truth created a
documentary,
maybe it would be convincing in the
other way.
You know what I mean?
It really depends on what perspective
you're coming from when you were
uneducated about the subject as you are.
I were kind of crazy and making a
conclusion one way or another.
Okay.
That's true.
But I mean there's a certain amount of
information that's widely available
about how the building was constructed
according to those guys,
according to the people who make it
widely available.
Who knows?
Who really built the building.
They built those buildings in New York.
That's a part of the problem.
They're skimping on the concrete and
fucking Joey,
what's up with this old rebar?
The thing's going to fall down during a
generalization about New Yorkers here,
but my people come.
The dirt.
She stay down.
No,
I
what my issue with all this is is that
you,
you came to this,
this instant conclusion that I probably
would have reached as well about me
about certain subjects.
Well,
if he believes as he probably believes
that if he's discussed this,
then he believes that if he's discussed
that,
then he believes that he's promoting
dangerous pseudoscience,
but I'm not.
I mean I certainly have promoted a
nonsensical idea in that we never went
to the moon,
but it was based on a lot of really
fascinating,
weird pieces of evidence that are really
amazing.
Once you start going down that rabbit
hole and following them and watching
the,
the Neil Armstrong speech that he gives
the 25 year anniversary speech where he
talks about removing truths,
hidden layers and all this weird cryptic
shit that he did and then all the shit.
When you're looking at the videos of
them bouncing around where it looks like
they're on trampolines.
If you're inclined to be conspiratorial,
it's all there for you.
The speech from President Clinton's book
where he talks about when he was working
with a carpenter,
when the first moon landings took place
in the carpenter,
told them that he didn't believe
anything.
Those TV fellers said that they could
show they could fake anything and put it
on TV,
and he said,
back then I thought that guy was a
quack,
but during all my years in the White
House,
I started to think maybe he was just
ahead of his time.
That's,
that's Bill Clinton in his book said
that.
So if you conspiratorially minded,
you start looking,
you know,
confirmation bias.
You start looking for things to confirm
your idea.
Look at these intersecting shadows,
man.
You know,
look at this picture.
Pictures fake.
Even if that picture is fake,
it still doesn't mean
go to the moon and consequently,
if you're inclined to think that nine
slash 11 was a government conspiracy,
you're going to be of the people who
spends the
most time,
quote unquote studying it,
which really makes means reading the
same stuff that confirms your belief on
the Internet.
Most likely.
Or you could be someone who's absolutely
obsessed with proving that nine slash 11
was not an inside job,
and you could,
you can chase that down and look at the
conspiracy of confirmation bias that
resulted in all these crazy books and
documentaries and all these different
things where people came to these
erroneous conclusions.
Who spends the most time looking at
pictures of Ufo
pilots,
astronomers or asleep checks.
Get a couple more of these.
Um,
yeah.
I would imagine it's people that are
obsessed and I would imagine that a lot
of those people were obsessed.
They are entertaining unhealthy ideas.
Okay.
Now that's what I said though,
a minute ago when we were talking about
architects and engineers on nine slash
11,
and you kind of jumped on my logic,
but that's not the.
But that's different.
We're talking about people that are
observing it,
not people who are trained in that
field.
When you get 2000 plus 2000,
100 people that are trained in that
field.
Me personally as a non architect and
non-engineer,
I have to look at it a little bit
differently.
There's,
there's nobody more trained in Ufo log
than you.
Apologists.
No,
no,
no.
Me.
I am the most trained in,
in euphology.
You don't even know.
I'm the guy.
If you have any questions to use this
because I just got it.
Do you need a go to guy?
I will give those guys ecstasy and
strippers and will,
will cure all this.
Search in the skies.
Bunch of unfuckable white dudes.
That's what we're dealing with,
Brian.
That's the real issue.
But you're right.
In some ways you're right in some ways
and we agree in some ways and,
and I absolutely agree with you that
I've been 100 percent irrational in the
past about certain things and also I get
caught up when I get into a discussion
with something about like,
like Phil plait with the Moon landings.
I'll get caught up in trying to be
correct or I'll get caught up,
caught up and trying to counter his
moves and treat it like it's a Jujitsu
match.
You know what I mean?
Why didn't you just make it a Jujitsu
match that weren't even in the room
together?
We were in the room together.
It probably would've worked out better.
He was on the phone and I was on the
phone once.
I was in studio once.
He was in studio once and we were on the
phone once.
Okay,
look,
let me ask you this question.
Are we on time,
by the way?
I have no idea.
I know we can go as long as we wanted.
Um,
we don't have a boss.
One of,
one of the things that,
um,
that I,
that I put in my,
in my paragraph about you,
which I hope to,
would love to completely redirect,
was a criticism of what you say so
often.
It's just that I'm just the guy asking
him questions.
Shouldn't we be looking at this?
Shouldn't we be asking these questions?
Am I saying that you.
Am I saying that right now?
I have said that asking questions,
Joe Rogan questions everything.
Oh yeah.
So,
right.
But when I'm.
Well,
if you go,
that's not a good example because if you
go over that,
it's me destroying pseudoscience.
If you go over that show,
it's like I got attacked by more people
that fucking believe in chem trails
because of that show,
explaining the actual science behind
this.
The thing that I sent you with Rosanne
where I explained the science behind jet
engines.
Great job by the way.
I thought you did a wonderful job going
and talking to Roseanne.
The chemistry.
Well that's all credit to request from a
metal bunk.
He was a software engineer and a
brilliant guy.
Software engineering or business.
What was the Tony Hawk did?
Tony Hawk
epic games and you know,
he sold his share in that and just
decided to debunk conspiracies and he's
brilliant at you know,
and he breaks it down so eloquently on
the show.
We brought them on the show to sort of
establish the science behind contracts
and chem trails.
So,
so my,
my,
my point with the whole asking
questions,
things and,
and,
and the validity of saying that it goes
a lot toward the,
the idea of visit.
Is it smart to debate questions of
pseudoscience?
I guess right now what's happening is
Bill Nye is A.
I'm not sure if it happened yet already,
but bill Nye is going to the creation
museum to debate creationists.
I know.
I heard about that.
Yeah.
Now there's that that triggers a lot of
pro and con thought in the,
in the science communication business
because many of us,
myself included,
think that it does more harm than good
because you're suggesting to anyone who
might be on the fence,
you're suggesting to them that there is
a debatable question here.
When you have something that is clearly
an established fact backed up by all
available evidence and something that's
crazy and has no possible evidence for
it.
We don't hold scientific debates about
that.
Um,
we move forward with our lives and when
you go out and you hold a debate,
when you agree to have a debate,
you're going to convince anyone who's on
the fence.
Oh,
maybe there is a question here that
needs to be looked at.
And in fact,
uh,
I,
I think it's arguable that you do more
harm than good.
And so by the same token,
I say that it's really possible when you
say,
Hey,
I'm just the guy asking questions about
building seven or whatever the subject
is,
that you're potentially doing more harm
than good by suggesting that there is a
questionable subject here.
Roswell,
let's take for example.
Hey,
I'm just thinking.
I asked him questions.
Isn't it strange that there were three
small bodies that needed coffins?
Well,
let's start with the,
the one one example.
Um,
you think that potentially addressing a
reality,
a reality in the way something looks,
that that could be dangerous,
that in somehow people could miss
through that,
misconstrue that for being support for a
conspiracy theory.
I think that when you take,
when you ask questions and you make an
argument that says,
hey,
shouldn't we ask questions about this?
Which is the answer is usually yes.
But when it's on a matter of basically
settled science,
I think you're doing more harm than good
by suggesting,
hey,
shouldn't we question whether two plus
two equals four?
Isn't it okay to ask,
does two plus two equals five?
Well,
you know that there's massive
inconsistencies in the studies that were
done about nine slash 11 that a disputed
about like the free fall speed.
I know there's a lot of anomalies that
people will picked out,
but I wouldn't say that there's any
inconsistencies.
The evidence
when we talking about technic testable
evidence that you can hold in your hand.
Well,
what I would mean by inconsistencies is
things that anomalies is a better word.
Things that you don't usually find like
buildings falling at free,
fall speed and then saying that is one
second less than free fall speed.
All these things fuel the,
the,
the debate,
all these things.
Get people excited about it,
but to deny that these things exist,
I think is silly because then you fueled
the conspiracy theories even more
because you're denying something that
seems obvious to the eye.
The eye,
the average person that looks at that
building says yes,
that does look like a controlled
demolition.
Does that mean it is?
No,
it doesn't,
but to pretend that it doesn't look like
that is ridiculous to about 10,
that is not odd that it falls at free.
Fall speed.
I'm not sure anyone is denying that.
It looks like a.
The part of it you can see in the video,
it does.
It looks exactly like a control.
You criticized me for what you agree
with that it looks like a controlled
demolition discussing.
You know,
that's not what.
That's not what I'm criticizing you for.
I agree that it looks like a controlled
demolition.
That's not the question.
The question is whether it should be
brought up now.
Well,
I mean you're,
you're,
we're sticking on this one example of
building seven.
We haven't resolved it yet.
It's a good example because it's an
example that you use as an example of
you thinking that if you listen to me
just describe what I see with my eyes
that it sounds to me like I'm supporting
some sort of a conspiracy theory when
I'm 100 percent not.
Okay.
Would you.
It seems like you have topics that are
off limits and that like this discuss
something like that.
Even did it to look at the reality of
the speed that it fell to Steven.
Bring it up is off limits.
Even if you say,
I don't believe in the conspiracy,
but isn't it crazy that building looks
like a controlled.
The only reason that this is a difficult
example to talk about is because it's
one that so ideologically charged,
right as his bill Nye talking about
creationism.
There's,
there's really,
there's really nobody who's on the fence
about that.
You're either a creation story or not.
I mean,
there might be some people who are on
the fence,
but there's a lot on me.
I don't quite buy it.
Well,
let's look at the numbers.
The Gallup poll,
the most recent Gallup poll on the age
of the earth was more than 46 percent.
Tell me more than 46 percent.
Think the earth is less than 10,000
years old.
I don't want to know.
It's shocking.
Well,
it's.
We know exactly where it comes from.
First of all,
how many of those people have been
exposed to actual science,
actual research,
actual data?
Someone who's really cosmetic,
like a neil degrasse Tyson,
who could break down the what we know
about science,
what we've done,
what great work has been shown that we
can carbon date things we know about the
date of stars.
We can follow the radio waves in this,
in that we can measure in space and
prove that there was a big bang 14
billion years ago.
All that stuff is so exciting that if
it's done correctly by a guy like Neil
Tyson,
it can be unbelievably culturally,
culturally valuable,
but those 46 percent of the people that
believed that the earth is 10,000 years
old,
I can almost guarantee that they
haven't had that in their life.
They just haven't been exposed to a
charismatic scientist or a documentary
that was unbelievably compelling.
That jived with their Christian ideology
so much they could absorb it.
You know,
there had been brainwashed.
They've been fucked over by their own
culture.
They've been fucked over by their
community.
They've been fucked over by these
dummies that raised them and taught them
this silly idea that so easily disproven
that it makes them a joke to anybody.
That's had any sort of formal education
whatsoever,
and it's almost half the population.
Let let me point out something that it
kind of a surprising similarity between
belief in creation as an belief in the
Kennedy,
the Kennedy assassination,
there are,
like we talked about,
there are a dozen law.
Well,
there's hundreds,
but let's say that there's a dozen
different kennedy conspiracies that are
mutually exclusive.
Just for sake of argument,
let's pretend it's a dozen.
Okay.
You've got about just as many theories
of creation.
Sure.
That are completely incompatible,
which is nothing existed until 6,000
years ago.
Everything poof appeared with exactly
the appearance of age you've got.
The earth is actually old,
but life is is a recent creation.
You've got all the other animals are old
and evolution happened in everything
except humans,
which were a special creation event.
You've got humans didn't evolve the way
science tells us,
but then suddenly we were given souls on
the Adam and eve day or you've got all
of these holidays now that we found a
columbus is an asshole.
Now you can eat.
You can come up with science and and lot
of people have they've.
They've come up with quote unquote
science to support each one of these
different theories.
Not really.
No,
no,
no.
What is in there?
What qualifies in their mind as
scientific support for.
Okay,
so exactly like the people who support
all these different versions of the
Kennedy conspiracy,
even though all of their theories are
mutually in mutually exclusive,
completely incompatible.
They all agree with.
They all consider themselves to be on
the same page in that they reject the
quote unquote official.
I find that to be a disingenuous
argument because the argument for the
earth being billions of years old,
the universe being billions of years old
is unbelievably unfathomably.
An overwhelming genius after genius has
broken down all the various particles of
the fucking universe and the dark matter
in the skies and the fact that inside
every black hole may ultimately be
another universe with hundreds of
billions of galaxies inside of it,
with black holes in each one of them
that the number of people that have
worked on provable conclusions about the
age of things using carbon dating or
what does the other way,
radiocarbon dating and what's the new
one that they're doing?
Well,
there's all sorts of,
but the sheer overwhelming numbers to
ignore that because you read some stupid
old book I think is way ridiculous than
to look at a guy who was murdered and
know that someone shot him and that it
might've been this guy that this other
gangster came and shot and killed,
but we'll never know because he's dead.
But so many other pieces.
Vince Bugliosi could sit here and make
exactly the same argument in reverse,
but he's chasing ghosts.
You're chasing ghosts.
You can't go back to 1963.
You know how you gonna prove what
happened
back to 6,000 years ago.
And so you were were you there and you
see dinosaurs running around a billion
years ago.
That's not.
That's not compatible because you could
take,
you could take a piece of wood and you
can carbon date that piece of wood and
you find out what this word is,
5,000 years old.
You can do that.
That's done.
That's a real thing when you're dealing
with the Kennedy assassination is,
yeah,
you've got some stories and yeah,
you've got some facts and yeah,
you've got some circumstances,
but putting it all together is a very
complicated series of events that took
place in order to kill that guy and take
his body and fly it to Bethesda,
Maryland and who gotten how to Jack
Ruby.
Get in there and who benefited from all
this.
There's a lot of variables and you are
also exist,
but hold on,
but variables that don't exist when
you're examining,
say like the core of the earth when
you're examining the birth and death of
stars,
hyper,
Novas,
all these things that we can absolutely
prove are a part of our natural world
we live in.
Okay,
but again,
you're talking down to you're,
you're,
you're ignoring the question of what
constitutes evidence because there are
people who will make a compelling speech
about why carbon dating is invalid.
Sure.
Maybe the Lord has changed the route,
the,
the speed at which a elements decay over
over the,
over the centuries.
Now that's something you can't argue
with because it's,
it's what we call a special pleading.
It's,
it's this,
as in humans,
we small humans are not able to
understand this and that's an argument
that can be used to defend just about
any pseudoscience or just about any
pseudo history.
So I mean you can apply exactly the same
thing.
Alternate versions of the Kennedy
history are always going to be just as
valid as alternate versions of the age
of the earth and devolution and it's,
it's,
they're made invalid in there.
They are presented as being valid using
evidence that cannot be argued against
because it's theoretical sort of here.
Here's the problem with the government.
The government has been proven time and
time again to be full of shit.
So when you look at official government
stories and you say,
well let's take this as our conclusion
and now let's work backward from here
and find out what,
what took place.
Well,
we know that Lee Harvey Oswald acted
alone because the government says,
we know that Jack Ruby was a bad guy and
he was very patriotic and he was really
sad and so that's why he did what he did
and case closed.
Wrap it up,
tie boom.
When you
and you look at all that,
it doesn't stand up to scrutiny.
It does,
doesn't.
It doesn't.
If you're dealing with a liar,
a liar told you this crazy story.
Damn man.
I was on your way over to your house,
man.
But a fucking asteroid came down and
knocked my tire off and I need another
tire side to wait in line and do what?
I'm so sorry I'm late.
You're like,
that guy's a liar.
He lies all the time.
He probably lied about this too.
Well,
if you're dealing with something like
the United States government that's
shown itself over and over and over
again to be full of shit,
it'd be very convenient to tell the
people what they want the people to
think rather than what is actually the
truth,
and then he start citing instance after
instance.
It's not just a blind accusations,
but instance after instance,
no longer do I think that it is not
likely,
nor is it logical to assume that the,
let's go official store,
which is a douchey term.
It's a very loaded term.
The official story makes it question,
but you to assume that the story that we
had been told in the mainstream media
and the news is correct.
It doesn't make sense.
Why would you assume it was correct,
but you're talking to a liar.
But scientists have told us that carbon,
that carbon dating works,
you know,
uh,
but we're talking about it's a matter of
faith in it.
We have to have faith in the scientists
to accept carbon.
Oh,
certainly not.
You read the science on it.
You read how they come up with the
conclusions.
I'm an idiot,
but I read about carbon dating when I
was trying to figure out why they could
figure out that dinosaurs existed 65
million years ago.
I'm unbelievably terrified and
fascinated by asteroidal impacts and
it's one of my main obsessions when it
comes to like late night freakouts
watching the discovery channel and you
know,
watching,
you know,
the,
just the idea that one day we could get
hit by one of these 800 plus thousand
near Earth objects that are fucking
gigantic stones flying through the
earth.
I'm fascinated by that shit.
So I got pretty deep into the whole idea
of carbon dating and the whole idea,
like how they figured it out and I've
read a bunch of articles on it and I
watched documentaries on it.
It's pretty easy to figure out from an
idiot's point of view,
like how they're doing it.
Like I don't understand the science
behind it.
I can't really replicate it,
but I listened to them describe it and
it clicks with me and it makes sense.
Okay.
But I mean,
so my argument is that
disagreeing with carbon,
dating,
disagreeing with the scientific view of
the earth is very similar to disagreeing
with kind of the standard model of
history,
standard monitor of the JFK
assassination.
As told I the US government.
I hate to use the term official story
because I don't care.
I've never read called the ls.
I've never read the Warren Commission
report.
I've never read the nine slash 11
commission report to be honest.
I don't know what's in them,
but I can tell you what happened to
Kennedy and I can tell you what happened
to what happened on nine slash 11
according to what I would call our
standard model of history,
which probably agrees and most respect
with the quote unquote official story.
The issue with the standard model of the
history of those is disseminated by the
US government.
People find easy to distrust.
No,
it's not.
It's not.
No.
When you were watching it on that
morning when you had your tv on,
you're watching the towers fall and
you're.
You've got broadcasters with the
microphone.
They were not being influenced by the
government.
They didn't have an earpiece in with
someone from the CIA telling them what
to say next.
You were pretty much watching it happen
through no government
filter.
Oh right,
but wait a minute,
but when you're talking about the
official story of it,
it's not the news being told as the
event goes down,
it's the explanation of why the event
took place after the fact that people
disagree with.
They don't.
No one disagrees that the towers fell
with that.
Planes hit them.
Sure they do.
There's people who think the planes were
holographs.
Okay.
You getting really crazy though.
Hey,
I mean there's.
There's all of these different theories
and while there's people that believe
the earth is hollow,
there's people that believe that life
is,
but a dream.
Merrily,
merrily,
hollow,
earth stories are awesome.
They're awesome.
They're all awesome.
I've,
I've talked to those people.
They were fucking crazy.
Well,
look,
people are nuts.
You know there there's people that
walked down the street and talk to
people that aren't there.
That doesn't mean that the government is
correct about Kennedy.
Doesn't mean that Lee Harvey Oswald
acted alone.
It doesn't mean that there's no nothing
other than the reason to conclude that a
single bullet in info inflicted all that
damage is nothing other than their need
to tie up the fact that they'd committed
to the idea of three bullets,
that that would be the only thing that
would be logical that this guy could get
off.
They.
Nobody thought he could get off four
bullets.
That was just like,
there's two crazy three.
Maybe he could fucking boom,
boom,
and get all three bullets in five
seconds with a milk road car Canto
Chicago.
When we were talking about that before I
was desperately on my ipad here.
I was trying to look up because at the
beginning of my episode I did a
recreation of the time of the Pouch
Pouch.
And then it's a long hell,
a long pause until the final shot pouch
shows it's something like nine seconds
or something.
And that's a long time.
I believe that they're a little less
than that.
But,
um,
I thought it was five.
But yeah,
that's the space between the last two
shots that the number of seconds that
you're usually told is the space between
the last one.
Also,
something against the conspiracy that I
would like to point out that people keep
pointing out was that the scope and that
rifle was off.
That was one of the things that people
kept saying that the scope and that
rife,
it was a bad scope.
As a someone who's fucked up their scope
before you could just put a rifle down
hard,
you drop it and it falls in the scope,
bounce off the ground that scopes off.
So the chain of evidence between Lee
Harvey on the idea that they found this
scope and it was impossible for them to
fight with his gun because the scope is
off is preposterous because anybody
could have dropped that gun after Oswald
left it there and fucked up that scope.
So the fact that who knows how many days
or hours or whatever,
later they went to check that scope to
see if it was cited in that stupid
hunters have to cite their scopes and
after every trip,
every time you put your stuff in luggage
packed in with all this like cushioning
and everything that makes sure in hard
cases you still have to recite your
scope and you get to a range.
You have to because to be ethical,
to make sure that you hit the animal
where you want to hit it because they go
off,
they bounce around,
they move.
Same issue with telescopes.
The sites on those are very similar.
So I mean that doesn't mean though that
you know,
the whole ball of wax,
the whole government story is exactly
what happened.
We're chasing ghosts.
Were talking about some shit from the
sixties and trying to piece it together
and say case closed I think is
preposterous.
I think it's ridiculous.
I do think it's fascinating and I do
think that people can lose their mind
and in and chasing it down and
investigating it.
And I certainly did myself back in
Pennsylvania when I was working at that
fucking club,
reading that stupid book all day and
then going on stage that night and just
bombing.
I mean I had two shows that night in the
first show.
I just ate a plate of shit.
And then the second show I pulled it
together and got back.
But I was depressed.
Why?
I mean,
what were you?
Were you were your child or getting your
material are always.
Oh No,
no,
no.
It's my mindset.
I've had to really distinctive times
where the things that I saw before I
went on stage fucked me up.
That was a big one.
That was probably the first one.
Might have been the second one.
It was all the same time.
It was a slow learner.
But the other one was I went with
this guy named jb smooth,
you know jb smoove funny.
He's hilarious.
And Jb and I were doing a college
together in New Jersey and jb was,
it was really hard to find.
And Jb was,
he was running late,
so they had me go on first and I wasn't
prepared because I was sitting in the
little rec room with a TV on and the TV
was showing this documentary on the
Malibu fires.
Uh,
it was so fucking depressing.
It was the early nineties and these
people lost everything and this guy was
crying.
He was a fireman and he was crying and
weeping.
His house was still there,
but it's neighbors had lost their houses
and he was just crying and weeping.
This girl was looking for her dog and
they're like,
all right Joe,
I'm jb is still late.
So what we're gonna do is we're going to
put you on and you do your sat and then
he'll go on after you.
I was like,
oh no.
So I went on stage thinking about this
guy crying,
not even for his own loss but for his
neighbors.
Last and that girl looking for a dog.
And I just got so sad and I went on
stage at a shit that just title,
even Japan really messed me up for a few
days.
I was.
So I'd been to Japan just a few years
before and man just seeing,
seeing all that destruction and you just
know,
you know,
watching those rivers,
Washington on the streets and
everything,
you know,
it's full of people.
And it was a,
I was messed up for days.
Yeah,
it's horrible.
So those comedy required.
I mean,
you know,
people are paying to see you take them
out of this reality and have them escape
into some fun world.
I wasn't good at it,
you know,
it was only.
I was only 20,
maybe 23 or something at the time I just
was clumsy.
I didn't know what the fuck I was doing
and the idea of reading this conspiracy
book all day and freaking out.
I also was bad at perspective.
Putting things in portfolio.
Listen,
this,
this took place in [inaudible] 63.
Here we are and you know,
1990.
Why am I thinking about this?
You know,
I didn't have that ability to switch
gears.
So interesting.
Well I stand up.
Comedy is,
is one of the careers that I have the
most respect for because you can't not
be smart and get away with it.
You've obviously never seen Brian
onstage.
He kills and he's not smart.
You've got it.
You've got to
be a great speaker.
You've got to be good on your feet.
I mean,
I,
I'm just impressed.
It's not a good speaker.
I barely can talk,
talk.
So he's got worms in his mouth.
Okay.
My,
my theory is disproven.
Well,
he,
um,
he also has a cheat code.
He's got the,
the God code became famous and then he
started doing comedy again.
It's your prop comedy without a proper
profit is his personality.
Well,
thank you.
I mean,
that's very nice of you to say.
Um,
it's a.
my friend Joey Diaz says it best.
He says it's the hardest,
easiest thing you'll ever do.
When you're good at it and you get good
at it and you stay at it and you develop
momentum,
then it's easy.
But to get to that point,
it's very hard.
And that,
that was my,
my birth or my.
I'm entering into the world of
conspiracies and the fascination with
them came from that,
from that one book,
100 percent,
no doubt about it.
That I can trace it back to that one
book that made me start questioning
reality of what I'd been taught.
Are there other roads you've gone down
that,
uh,
that you've since turned away from the
Moon landings?
Most drastic,
like again,
I say for,
you know,
just as a caveat,
I always wish the moon landing was fake
and I would be much more happy if it
turned out it was a giant hoax then if
people went to the moon,
why?
Because I'm a silly bitch and because I
like silly things and I love,
I think it'd be a greater accomplishment
for people to fake that we went to the
moon.
They would almost even be to go to the
I mean,
that was what Neil said.
Yeah.
Well that's also with the,
you know,
I mean,
a lot of people that have argued against
it have said,
yeah,
science even scientifically that it
would be more impressive.
It would.
And I think,
uh,
the,
the point that,
uh,
the number of people who would be
expected to keep a secret as well.
Okay.
This is something that,
um,
we have a road.
We went down with the flight was flight
93 or flight 77 flight 93 was the one
that got shot down over Pennsylvania 93.
So I've got a friend who does not
believe in any of the nine slash 11
conspiracies,
except he believes that we did
successfully shoot down that plane.
Well,
I will tell you this without saying
anyone's name or speaking any further
that I know people that are in the
military and I asked them,
is it possible that in a situation where
a plane was going to be flown into the
Pentagon,
that they would have fighter jets it out
of Scott?
Do you think that would be possible?
And they said 100 percent.
Yeah.
One hundred percent possible.
Oh,
we would do it.
We had to.
We had plans on the way to do it.
Yeah.
They didn't get there in time.
Allegedly.
I,
I have,
I have no problem with the fact that
they were on the way to get it,
but,
but the thing is that that's another
case where you got to look at the number
of people involved because if a missile
gets shot,
a missile getting shot is a big deal
because you've got all kinds of
accounting that has to happen for that.
Not,
not only do you have the ground crew and
everyone's supposed to spend this long
just shakes it off.
You've got civilian oversight for all
the supplies that happen.
Again,
for a plane to shoot a missile that
nobody knows about,
that's again going to involve,
you know,
a pyramid of people,
100 people at the base may be at a
minimum,
a thousand people in the civilian
oversight contractors.
It just goes on and on and on.
The number of people that would have
wished that I could agree with that I,
but I can't because of the fact that
they have black funded projects because
of the fact that they develop things in
total complete secrecy in area 51 that
involve billions and billions of
dollars.
That's where the technology came from.
That's where you know many different
advanced technologies have come from
without any knowledge whatsoever by the
American people.
So to say that it would be hard to hide
a missile,
it would certainly be an issue.
We'd certainly be an issue,
but I don't think that a government that
could make a fucking stealth bomber
would have a hard time hiding a missile.
Well okay.
But these planes did not come from area
51.
They can totally open basis trail walk
on and off of it day.
That's true.
But if you can.
Well people walk on and off of the area,
51 everyday too.
They just come in by buses.
They just come in on planes and buses
from,
from Vegas.
But that doesn't necessarily mean that
that's,
that's what happened.
But it does.
The idea of saying this could never
happen because you would have too many
people not really think about all the
shit that they have designed that no one
knew they had until they had this.
There's a lot of secrecy still in
government when they do it right and
they're really good at it.
When it comes to national security,
they can keep things take,
but.
But also those things weren't all that
remarkable.
There was nothing.
Nothing that ever happened at area 51
turned out to really be all that
interesting.
Blackbird.
Yeah.
You don't think that that's remarkable.
These unbelievable jets.
You don't think that stealth technology
is remarkable.
The fact that they look like Ufo and
they can hide from radar.
God Damn.
You're hard.
No,
I go to google.
Com.
Google came from really area 51.
Oh,
you're joking.
No,
I mean there's.
There's being.
Well,
I'm buying it and anyone can get
started.
I'm a big aerospace nut and I follow a
lot of the aerospace reporting and
anyone,
anyone in that industry knows what goes
on at area 51 because it's basically
the.
It's the national test facility is what
it's actually called.
They simply,
that's where they're testing the next
generation planes.
I wouldn't be surprised to see what
they're testing.
They're now,
uh,
because we pretty much have a pretty
good idea of what it looks like.
And that's the,
that was the case in the 19 sixties was
the case in the 19 seventies.
You've obviously never seen the
interviews with Robert Lasar know our
favorite guy.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
You have.
Oh,
I know all about Bob.
Hello?
Sorry.
Yeah,
I,
I did a whole episode on,
on his thing as well.
He's a fascinating cat because he seems
so smart.
And then you finally,
he lied about his college education
know.
Oh,
I think you might be crazy.
Yeah.
That,
that,
that was a,
that was really quite a wonder.
But anyone who is in the note was
laughing at him from the beginning.
Oh,
really?
Only fooled people in the Ufo community.
Well,
that sounds like an ad hominem attack,
sir.
And that doesn't do very much to support
your arguments.
So
was terrible debating skill you have
here,
Brian Dunning.
He was wrong because of who he is to the
end.
Um,
nobody wants us to be real more than me,
like nobody wants to dig for it to be
real more than me.
Now I'm silly.
I'm a silly person.
I'm a comedian,
you know,
I don't have any vested interest in
keeping the status quo and standard
operational procedure in place.
I like it all falling apart.
I would love it if a Ufo flood flow over
the city and people started shitting
their pants and throwing bed pans out
the windows.
I would love it.
I told you what,
when I first got here to the studio,
I told you that bigfoot is something
that I believed in until five years ago.
Fairly recent.
Well,
not just that.
You said you believe the Patterson
Gimlin footage.
Oh yeah.
No,
I,
I always believed that the Patterson
Gimlin footage,
um,
do I just call it pattern and Kim
leadership.
I always believed that that looked
incredibly good and I still do now.
The people who say that's the worst fake
I've ever seen.
I think they're being disingenuous
because I think it's a brilliant face.
I think it looks great.
You're hilarious.
I know the whole history of the film and
everything.
Um,
and Bob.
Yeah.
The whole thing with,
you know,
when was the film where,
when was the film purchase?
Was it developed?
How did it get from A to b?
And we know that pretty much everything
he said about it was a lie and we pretty
much have a good picture of the film's
history and we know that it was faked.
We also know that he was arrested for
larceny,
for writing a bad check.
He was very camera that he used to film
and he had been paid.
He was on a hunt to make a big foot
documentary for God's sake.
Don't bring this up to bobcat.
Goldthwait crazy.
Crazy.
We had on my show.
I had um,
uh,
well,
here's,
here's the video.
Let's watch the video real quick just so
we can show how silly you are that you
think that this looks real.
The stabilized version,
because this one's horrible because this
is how it was first released.
It was first released in this sort of
like weird,
shaky,
shaky version.
Um,
this is actually probably stabilized
because it,
I mean,
I think that looks so stupid and fake.
How can you say it looks fake because
it's so bad quality.
Exactly.
If there was anything in there that gave
it away,
like a Zipper,
it wouldn't be visible because of the
low graininess the way he walks.
He walks like a person.
I mean,
it doesn't mean that it's not a big
giant person,
but he walks like a person and I don't
think when you watch an elephant walk,
there's,
there's a reality to the weight that
they carry around and that thing is not
walking with the reality of the weight
of an 800 pound,
1000 pound animal.
That thing is walking.
Maybe he's,
maybe he's five,
six.
Well,
they decided they were going to measure
off all the different trees in that area
and figure out how tall he was.
I didn't say I thought it looked like he
was over six feet tall.
I said it looked like a real animal to
me.
Well,
it doesn't.
To me it looks like a guy in a monkey
suit.
It looks stupid.
I'm what I'm doing is I'm,
I,
I'm admitting where I have had,
where susceptible
to,
you know,
I wanted big foot to be real.
I understand.
And in,
in finding yourself that you were indeed
a silly bitch.
Now what you're doing is you're bouncing
the other way and going was,
I'm sorry,
excuse me at the time,
and now you're,
you're bouncing completely the other way
and hardcore skeptic,
a skeptic by,
by,
not by choice,
but by default,
instantly,
automatically lean towards the skeptic.
Shouldn't we all be?
I think we should be very objective for
sure,
and I think it can be very confusing if
you're not,
you know,
if you do go looking around for
conspiracies,
the,
the better alternative is most certainly
to be skeptical by default,
but I also think that you,
you miss a lot of shit.
Like,
okay,
here's a perfect example and I use this
one all the time.
Unfortunately for people listening to
podcasts.
Do you believe that nine slash 11
happened?
Do you believe that planes flew into
buildings?
Do you believe that happens?
Yes.
Then you believe in conspiracies?
Yes,
yes.
They conspired to do that and they
pulled it off.
A bunch of people hijack planes
simultaneously in different spots in the
country.
They got control of the planes,
flew those planes into buildings.
Causal buildings collapse.
Thousands people died.
It was a conspiracy.
It was a successfully executed
conspiracy and only one of many that we
know of all throughout history.
So if you automatically take the skeptic
point of view,
you miss out on the possibility of
exposing something that is a true
conspiracy because they do exist.
Well,
when you say the skeptic point of view,
what do you mean how I would say the
null hypothesis,
the null hypothesis is that Lee Harvey
Oswald acted alone.
The null hypothesis is that probably
nothing remarkable happened.
Well,
why would you say that?
okay.
Remarkable things happen all the time
though.
Why would.
Why would that be a fault?
Okay,
you're what?
What?
What I mean in that case is take the.
Take the guy for a different example of
a shooting.
Take the guy who shot all the people at
the movie theater.
The null hypothesis is that a guy shot
all the movie people in the movie
theater as was reported by everyone who
was there,
right?
The null hypothesis and the Kennedy
situation would be that Lee Harvey
Oswald acted alone as discovered by the
cops who chased him down and tackled him
and arrested him in the movie theater.
The null hypothesis for nine slash 11
would be that what happened generally as
well as we saw it on television and was
reported by the people where there is
what happened.
That's that would be the null hypothesis
and anything remarkable would be
something that goes against what appears
to have happened on that day.
So I would say that the null hypothesis
is going to generally be right most of
the time until we've got some remarkable
evidence to prove it wrong.
How do
you factor in contradictory evidence
from reputable online news sources?
Like,
like for example,
like let's,
uh,
the NSA.
It's perfect example before it was
revealed by Edward Snowden that the NSA
was indeed spying on all these different
Americans and detailing records of your
phone calls.
And who was surprised by that?
Very few people were,
but the people were had argued
against it via millie and they had said,
there's no way there would be such a
huge conspiracy.
You'd have to hide that from so many
people.
So many people would be in the know.
There's no way that that could be
possibly true.
I heard that.
I.
I witnessed Alex Jones having that
discussion with a person where Alex
Jones,
who predicted this shit a long time ago,
almost a decade before it actually
happened,
I believe it was 2003 or four.
Alex Jones was saying,
if you don't think they're keeping
detailed records of every phone call,
you make everything you do,
every email you send.
He was on it way before and I thought it
was crazy nutty conspiracy talk.
Meanwhile,
he was right.
They really were.
They really,
really figured out how to do it.
They developed this technology.
They created this storage facility that
they're in the middle of the building
right now in Utah.
That's going to be this massive
warehouse of data and information.
That's a real conspiracy.
That turned out to be true.
I don't think that there was.
Well,
I can't say that Alex,
you,
I don't give him credit for predicting.
How dare you.
There's nothing.
There's nothing that snowden revealed
that I don't think was pretty much
generally suspected.
Anyway.
We know that cell phone companies have
always had all your cell phone records.
Therefore the government has them.
That's not surprising to me.
Well,
they could access that.
Surprising that someone would be
surprised by that.
Really.
That's funny because I thought it was a
pretty big revelation cause for alarm.
A lot of people were up in arms about
it.
It was a pretty big deal.
I don't think they have.
I think people have always been up in
arms about it.
There's been a lot of people saying,
Hey,
the self privacy,
the cell phone company shouldn't have
any way to track my calls or or to do.
But they can and they own their cell
phone company so they can do whatever
the heck they want and as long as those
records exist,
it's pretty naive to believe that nobody
has access to them.
Well,
sure.
That is not the issue.
The issue is that they're doing it for
every single American all the time.
They constantly following you and
constantly watching your emails and
constantly that it's not a matter of
looking at suspicious,
suspicious people or people that have
been accused of crimes.
It's a matter of people that are just
law abiding citizens that are taxpayers
and doing nothing wrong,
but yet they're being almost like held
because they're checking all their
information.
It's like this thing that they hold over
your head and the idea that this could
be used to intimidate political
opponents so this could be used to
intimidate business rivals.
You know,
that that was a huge conspiracy and I
think to,
to deny that that was pretty shocking to
the American people when we found out
that they not only did indeed have this
power and capability,
but they had been utilizing it for a
long time.
Some things only shocking if you didn't
have enough information to be aware of
that that was going on.
Um,
and I,
I mean I come from the Silicon Valley
background and
with the formation of all the big,
the big search engines and things like
that,
having worked at enormous ridiculously
huge data centers and everything and
having a general idea of how the
technology works.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's to me it's nothing,
nothing in that is surprising that,
that,
that data is being collected on that
large of a scale or that anyone would
have access to it.
Nothing.
Nothing I've heard coming from snowden
surprised me in any way and wouldn't
surprise most of the people from a
similar background as me I think.
I think for a lot of people is quite
shocking.
I'm sure it was.
But,
um,
but I think if you,
if you know anything about the way the
technology works and about that,
the whole data storage and collection
industry,
you know,
the null hypothesis has got to be that
hey,
anyone who wants access to it has access
to but in wasn't the no hypothesis when
Obama gave that speech and said that
we're not doing it and this is just
metadata.
And when didn't believe people believe
that it wasn't that essentially what
everyone was reporting in the news and
everyone was saying,
listen,
this is much ado about nothing.
This is just metadata.
Don't worry.
And then it turned out that that wasn't
the case at all.
Well,
the null hypothesis also,
I think that the government,
the government maybe,
maybe,
uh,
maybe a presidential press releases are
not always exactly accurate to a federal
truth.
How do we apply that to everything else?
How do we apply that to the Kennedy
assassination?
And how mean the nutters hear this and
they're going to apply it.
Sorry for calling.
You notice folks,
but the nine slash 11 truther,
how about that?
There they apply that to nine slash 11.
Truth there say this is you're
contradicting yourself.
The whole idea that what they're saying
is,
is not the null hypothesis or what do
you mean will you said that the
government tends to be a liar when it
comes to press conferences.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
I got you.
And an official story.
The official story is is a lie because
it's the official story because it's
coming from the government compared to
the null hypothesis being that the
government always lies about everything
or a frequently is not completely
truthful.
Well,
no,
it wasn't a no hypothesis that the story
that's being produced in the media is
the actual story that whatever the,
the,
the conclusions that mainstream is
accepted about Osama bin Ladin and these
hijackers from Saudi Arabia and all
these different things that factor into
the events of nine slash 11 are in fact
exactly how it went down when you in
fact just said that when it comes to
like the NSA and the Obama
administration not being correct or
being truthful about metadata and what
was being collected that well,
the United States government tends to
lie well.
If they tend to lie,
they tend to lie and if they tend to
lie,
why would you assume that there are
other explanations for all the different
things that have taken place for true at
all?
It wouldn't be the happy.
It's just fascinating subject and
obviously very complicated,
but that's my point.
That's the point.
Yes,
but,
but also when you say the official
story,
when you're talking about what the
government says,
that's not necessarily the source of
information that people are relying on.
Nobody has read the nine slash 11
report.
Nobody has read the Warren Commission
You and I,
we don't even know what the government's
position is on those.
We assume we do.
We assume that it's whatever's in those
reports,
what people generally
believe about it,
but that's not our source of
information.
We didn't go to the government for our
I've.
I don't think I've ever had a question
about nine slash 11 that I've gone and
googled a government website to find out
what the,
what,
what should have happened,
what I'm supposed to be
belief is.
I don't think anything.
There are government websites and spell
out history.
Is there a government website?
It's history.
I don't think that exists.
I have no.
It fucking crushed that thing.
The thing is you,
you can't conflate the government's
version of events with.
That's why I like to use the term,
the standard model.
The standard model is what,
you know,
probably most historians,
p,
whatever,
whatever the field is,
whatever the scientists are,
whatever the historians are,
if it's a historical weather,
what,
what most lawyers think,
if it's a legal question,
I don't,
I would call it the standard model.
I would not use the term of the official
story because that suggests government
involvement,
which is not not an authoritative
source.
The government,
quote unquote,
is not an authoritative source on
anything.
It's not where people get their nine
slash 11 information.
We get that from basically from
historians,
you know,
for,
from modern history.
It's not the official source on how many
neutrons are in a boron,
Adam,
you know,
that's,
we get that from the standard model of
science.
So,
um,
I,
I don't think it's too much of a,
I don't think it's hypocritical for me
to say that I'm a boy.
I'm twisting myself into knots here.
I don't think it's hypocritical for me
to say that when Obama says something
that we shouldn't accept as the truth,
um,
that,
that conflicts with the government's
official position on nine slash 11 or
snowden or what the end of the Kennedy
assassination.
I think what I'm saying makes sense.
Well,
the,
the issue with that is,
of course the news outlets,
especially in the Kennedy assassination,
got all their information from the
government.
They got all the reports from
spokespersons that were assigned this
position to give this press conference
and explained what the details are where
the president was found.
Bethesda,
Maryland.
What do you think?
That guy got his talking points as he
winging it,
you know,
they're not winging it.
Those guys were told what to say and
when to say it,
and they were put on television because
it was an easily controlled thing back
then there.
The reporters on the site.
Sure.
But what do they know whether they know,
they know the president was dead and
then they took the president's body
away.
Everything else is information from the
government.
Well,
I mean,
what does that mean?
Were they handed a press release that
says White House at the top and Said
told report this?
Well,
it depends on where were they getting
their information.
Depends on.
I mean there's many,
many,
many outlets.
There's,
there's different.
You know,
doctors had talked about it.
There's different people who were on the
news.
There's Tom who is the guy who explained
it on television for the first time,
that classic speech that the president
has been shot.
Goddammit.
Who was it that famous Daniel Grant?
I don't believe it was Dan Rather.
I think.
I believe it was before his time.
I want to say it doesn't.
I don't know.
It's pointless.
The point is that where are they getting
that information?
I'm asking.
I don't see how the government fits in
that loop.
Will the government had body and they
released
a press statement.
That's fact.
I mean they tell people that the
president has been shot.
The president's dead.
This is what's going on and you know
when the news outlets,
whether it's local or national,
ABC,
NBC,
whatever it is,
they need to get the information from
the official source.
The official source would be someone
who's in the government that has a press
conference that explains the events as
they took place.
Okay.
So
what kind of spinning around in circles
here that might be annoying for people?
I was,
yeah.
I was basically going to circle where I
would say the same thing.
We agree on more than we disagree on and
I think that what I'm trying to say is
that there's weirdness to the world and
that to automatically take the skeptical
position is oftentimes just as silly as
automatically taking the conspiratorial
position.
Okay.
What do you mean
by the skeptical position?
What do you mean when you say,
uh,
from,
from you that I'm,
I'm,
I'm getting the message that you think I
tend to take a silly position.
No,
no,
no.
Skeptical that it is silly to take this.
I don't want to be fooled.
Position just as foolish as it is
sometimes to take this blue double
double that either when Phil crazy,
just as silly as it is to automatically
knee jerk,
take the conspiratorial position when we
know for a fact that certain
conspiracies have not just been planned
out,
but had been executed,
whether it's the Gulf of Tonkin that led
us into Vietnam,
whether it's operation northwoods,
which was a planned attack on American
civilians and American military that was
signed by the Joint Chiefs of Staff.
They were going to make a jetliner
explode.
They were going to arm Cuban friendlies
and have them attack Guantanamo Bay.
All of this to blame on the Cubans so
that we could go to war with Cuba when
you know that that kind of information
exists and was real and it's provable
and it's in the freedom of Information
Act releases when you know about all
that,
that has to be factored into the,
uh,
the spectrum of possibilities.
Okay?
But you can't,
you can't
use the fact that there have been real
conspiracies and history.
You can't use that to defend conspiracy
theories because conspiracy theories as
defined by the way you and I are
discussing them,
our future predictions,
that conspiracy theory about nine slash
11 and having been an inside job,
for example,
predict that one day it will be
discovered that the government
orchestrated nine slash 11.
It's A.
It's a prediction of evidence that will
someday have exist in the future and
future predictions really have never
come true.
I,
I say that there.
I've said this in print many times,
that there are no conspiracy theories
that have ever come true.
A conspiracy theory being something that
has existed as a theory among conspiracy
theorists unknown to the general public
unknown.
I'll dispute that right away.
That one.
What about the LSD experiments that they
did on civilians?
That was,
that did not exist as a conspiracy
theory until it was discovered.
Well,
most certainly did it.
It just existed in my high school.
We talked about them doing lsd
experiments on soldiers.
It was an urban legend.
It was a myth that they gave soldiers
lsd and they,
they,
they drag
people to find out what the asset would
do to them and it rotted their brain
out.
We'd hear all these stories.
You could hear about it from people that
were in the military.
You're talking about Mk ultra.
I'm not talking about Mk ultra.
I'm talking about operation midnight
climax where the CIA drugged up people
that were in brothels in New York and
San Francisco so that they can study the
effects of Lsd on innocent civilians.
I'm talking about here.
We're talking about.
So I think that was part of Mk ultra
mean.
There was,
there was a lot of programs related to
him.
Basically the same operation,
midnight,
19 fifties,
forties,
fifties.
That's pretty early.
Well,
it was also the,
the various things that they did to
soldiers.
Many of them documented to this day.
There were all legends at one point in
time.
Those were all the,
the mind control experiments that they
did to Timothy.
Uh,
what's his name?
The unibomber.
What's his name?
Tim [inaudible].
Ted Kaczynski.
He was a part of the,
uh,
the,
the Harvard Lsd Studies,
Ted Kaczynski.
They fucking does that guy have with
acid.
I didn't know that as.
He was very cool.
There was a documentary on it,
I think it was called the net and it was
all about tracing back the roots of his
insanity to these,
these lsd experiments and that he may
very well have signed up for something
that fried is fucking brain.
Okay.
Let me,
let me,
let me ask her something right now.
Ask.
I'd like to ask your listeners of whom
you have,
how many don't know what we're talking
about more than it definitely.
I'd like to ask for all of all of Joe's
listeners out there,
if you have an example of a conspiracy
theory that existed as a theory among
conspiracy theorist before it became
generally known by law enforcement,
media,
general,
public,
whatever.
Please let me know.
Email me,
Brian at [inaudible] dot com because I
still maintain that there are none and I
would love to be proven wrong about this
and what the what Alex Jones said,
isn't that a conspiracy theory that
turned out to be true that the
government is spying on your emails and
listening to all your phone.
That wasn't something that was known
only to conspiracy theorists.
That was something that's.
I mean that's.
That wasn't surprising.
I,
I can tell you because you were in the
number of the people who were in that
industry.
That doesn't surprise me,
but from someone like me,
it was very surprising and for people
that were listening to the official
government story,
it was absolutely contradicting.
Okay,
and the first time you learned about
teen conspiracy theories,
that turned out to be true.
Let's read.
Okay.
Yeah.
You're funny.
I hear your voice is not objective,
sir.
Cancer viruses into other vaccines.
Atm Machines will someday use facial
recognition technology.
Yeah,
but those are silly.
Those are not conspiracy theories.
That's just prognosticating.
This is just crazy.
And projecting.
Well,
there must be something in there.
The US government and Monsanto are
teaming up against opponents of agenda,
kinetically modified food.
It's not a conspiracy theory.
It's not know kind of is that the US
government and Monsanto are teaming up
to make money pro wrestling's fake.
Whoa.
That's not real.
Shut the fuck up,
dude.
Do.
Don't break my break.
My word world in half a scientists all
over the world are creating extremely
bizarre human animal hybrids.
Okay.
Is this true?
Not long ago,
Chinese scientists embedded genes for
human milk proteins into a mouse genome
and have since created herds of
humanized milk producing.
Well,
that's just ignorance.
They don't understand what what's going
on there.
They.
They're not making human hybrids.
They're just utilizing genes for certain
specific actions.
Using a cell phone could cause cancer.
Yeah.
That's not been proven unless you talked
to Sheryl Crow.
Crow thinks she got a brain tumor from
listening to the cell phone all the
time.
Fluoride is harmful for your teeth.
Okay.
Is that true?
Department of Health and Human Services
and environmental protection agency are
proposing the change because of an
increase in fluorosis,
a condition that causes spotting and
streaking of children's teeth.
These are not conspiracy theories.
This is a bad promotions of anti
science.
This is stupid prescription drugs kill
large numbers of Americans to the
fucking.
Everything kills people,
but if somebody,
if someone out there does have a
conspiracy theory that turned out to be
true,
please email me at [inaudible] dot com.
I would.
I would love to be able to report on it.
One of those,
one of the most,
one of those common episode requests I
get is for conspiracy theories that
turned out to be true and I always
answered that email with the same thing.
I said,
great.
Give me a suggestion.
I've been looking for him.
A lot of the times they confuse
incompetence with conspiracy as well.
Like here's one.
The Federal Reserve is a perpetual debt
machine that is designed to create
inflation.
Then it goes onto to show the US
national debt has gotten more than 5,000
times larger than the value of the US
dollar has fallen by more than 96
percent.
I think that's more of an example of
greed and incompetence and just fucking
fools running things than it is a
massive conspiracy to diminish the
wealth of the United States.
Just people are stealing from the
system.
That's all it is.
They put cancer viruses in our vaccines
because you know this Brian Denny,
I know that they've got all kinds of
different things in vaccines for
different purposes and a lot of the
times what the things that people report
like there are a boarded fetal tissue in
vaccines that's not completely untrue.
There are a certain certain certain
lines that can only be grown in human
tissue and so there's two particular
lines of fetal tissue that have existed
for boy,
I think they're 40 or so years old now.
These two particular lines and we grow
the cultures in those in those tissues
have a human tissue and then the.
The.
The cultures are removed from the tissue
once in a while.
Have spare cell or something will get
stuck in and be included with the
vaccine,
but it's not harmful in any way and it's
kind of misrepresents the white happens
to say that,
uh,
we include human fetal tissue in
vaccines.
Someone sent me one that's legit.
The Gulf of Tonkin incident never
happened.
That was a conspiracy theory long before
it was ever proven.
True.
That's true.
I haven't done an episode on that.
That's been a frequent request.
I'll put that.
I'll put that,
bump that to the top of my.
That's a real one,
but I have a feeling that you're going
to somehow or another shaded so that
everything's gonna be okay.
You're going to dance around it and make
it seem like,
listen,
don't worry about me.
What about the Gulf of Tonkin was known
only to conspiracy theorists before law
enforcement slash media slash whoever
got ahold of it.
That's a good question.
Uh,
well,
that's,
that's what we're looking for.
How about the fact that it happened at
all?
That they,
they actually did fake this incident
that is established historical facts.
But that's saying that a conspiracy
happened.
Sure.
But that's not the same thing as a
conspiracy theory happened,
but no,
it was serious theorist who were,
who were shouting about it on the street
corners before it was discovered by the
general public or by law enforcement.
Really.
Sure that that was something that people
had talked about.
I don't know.
I mean obviously I'm too young to know,
but the Gulf of Tonkin conspiracy.
But I mean that's,
that's the information I'm looking for.
Yeah.
I wouldn't have conspiracy theorists
who,
you know,
from their New York apartment basements
or wherever they were figured out these
things.
Yeah.
I don't,
I can't say before with people who
should have known about them,
found out about them.
What about Watergate?
Well,
that's not really a conspiracy theory.
What that is,
is just standard operational procedure
amongst crux.
And then one guy got busted.
There was,
there was nobody knew that was Alex
Jones was not on his radio shows
screaming about what happened about
Watergate.
Well,
he was a baby Bernstein and Woodward
report.
It wasn't even a baby.
He wasn't even born then.
Alex,
he's younger than me.
He looks like he's 60,
but he's like,
I think it's 40.
Really?
Yeah.
He's a young guy.
When I first met him,
I believe he was 28 is actually younger
than me.
Correctly.
That's depressing.
Yeah,
he does look pretty bad.
Doesn't he?
Fucking burns at both ends.
Alex.
I'm sorry if you're listening.
He says,
sweetie,
Jesus,
he's a sweetie.
But yeah,
he's fucking.
Look,
if you,
your whole day was doing gloom and new
world order,
he'd be shitting your pants too.
Um,
I don't know if we got anywhere with any
of this talk,
but we still have plenty of time.
So,
um,
let's,
let's continue.
I think I could shed light on a faulty
thinking that I have had myself please.
And I think,
um,
I think that confirmation bias and that
you can go online and find French sites
and all these different things that
support your ideas and then not
objectively look at it like completely
objective.
We all get attached.
We get our egos attached to statements
and we get our egos attached to
positions that we've taken.
And I think that those,
those,
those egos and those statements and
positions that we've taken oftentimes
can be the enemy of objectivity.
And I agree with you that there are
most.
I wouldn't say most things,
but when you're looking at information
online,
what you should do is look at all the
different arguments,
pro and con,
and then look where the intelligence is
liquid.
Look where the smart people are leaning.
Look where the educated people are
leaning liquid.
The experts are leaning and try to
figure it out and also know that no
matter what there is in this world,
if you haven't been there and you know
you're,
you're reading someone's take on it,
there's going to be a bunch of different
opposing
opinions that make no fucking sense.
There's going to be some that are close.
There's going to be the full range from
from fucking whack a doodle.
The planes were holograms.
There was explosions that were looking
at.
This is not a civilian plane.
You know,
they,
they took the people to the moon.
There's this wackadoodle shit on,
on every subject,
everything that exists.
And some of it you have to wonder,
you know,
we know that there's techniques and
tactics of disinformation while they'll
take a bunch of things that are
absolutely true.
Then attachment to one thing that's
blatantly ridiculous,
and that one thing sort of diminishes
all the other things.
One thing that I always tell people and
I always get criticized for it is if you
have a question on any given matter,
go to the experts in that,
in that subject,
if you want to know,
you know how old the earth is,
go to the people who actually work in
that field.
You're not always going to be right,
but you're going to be right far more
often than you're wrong.
So no matter what the question is,
what the pseudo sciences,
for example,
you know,
a cancer bullshit,
cancer remedies.
If you want to know whether this works,
go to go to the experts in cancer,
go to the American cancer society,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
You won't always be right,
but you'll be right far more often
then you're wrong.
We had a real problem with that on our
show with um,
Peter Duesberg.
Peter Duesberg,
who's a professor of biology at the
University of California,
Berkeley,
uh,
esteemed scholar who also believes that
HIV doesn't cause aids and we had him on
the podcast and it was unbelievably
baffling and my statement was,
it's very frustrating when you're too
dumb to know who stupid,
but it was listening to him and
listening to the absolute outrage of all
the actual scientists that work in the
field of HIV research and how angry
people were about it.
And unfortunately I couldn't get anybody
to debate him and I think that much like
people are criticizing Bill Nye of
visiting the creation museum is almost
like people don't want to debate
holocaust deniers.
They did not want to debate this guy
because somehow or another it gives his
ideas.
Yeah.
And I agree with that.
I would say just let them hang out in
the wind for anyone with any credibility
to spend time on that.
You're just,
you're communicating to the general
public that there's a question here that
needs to be looked at and that's not
right.
Yeah.
It's baffling though.
It's really confusing when you have this
guy.
It was just an incredibly intelligent
man who's very well respected in
educated and has done some amazing work
on cancer research as well.
So even since then,
so it's,
it's,
it's baffling.
Okay.
Let me,
let me ask you something else.
I want to kind of call you out a little
bit on something else.
Um,
it's call you out of some new shit that
people are doing in the last 10 years.
No sense.
Right on.
It was.
No,
that's good.
Before that,
nobody ever did any conspiracy theorists
believed that there would calling them.
So.
Okay.
You had a guy on your show a couple of
weeks ago.
I tried to listen when I come on the
show,
I try to listen to some recent episodes.
You had a guy on who was a doctor Dr
something or rather Gordon.
Mark.
Mark Gordon Martin.
Okay.
I,
I listened to that episode.
I turned it off in a rage at nine
minutes because I couldn't take anymore.
Okay.
He came on and I believe you said you'd
had them on several times before.
Is that right?
No,
he's my friend.
Okay.
You know,
the guy he came on and he starts
promoting his miracle supplement that
you take and you can drink as much
alcohol as you want,
not to get drunk.
Well,
he's talking about glutathione.
It wasn't,
wasn't saying it was me.
He was selling a product that you can
take it and you know he doesn't sell.
It doesn't sell gludethyon.
I might.
He might beg to differ.
That was the.
That was the central thrust of the first
nine minutes.
The episode I listened,
but what I want,
what I want,
I might be correct or incorrect.
What I want to discuss with you is
something you said to him,
you said,
you said that sounds too good to be
true.
[inaudible].
I wish I knew enough to call you out on
your bullshit.
Right.
You should have.
You should have known enough to call
them out on your bullshit.
I didn't know he was gonna.
Bring that up if you're going to.
Well,
I mean,
okay.
What?
It wasn't like this.
The topic of conversation,
like when when I have some on the show,
the the idea of having people in the
show is just a conversation just with
you.
There's no.
We didn't discuss much.
We said,
let's just have fun.
Let's just talk.
The same thing with mark.
Mark is a friend of mine and he's an
interesting guy and he can ramble on
forever and relay all sorts of
information.
He's also an expert in traumatic brain
injury,
has helped a lot of soldiers,
helped a lot of athletes,
have a lot of football players,
mixed martial arts fighters,
boxers.
He's.
He's helped a lot of people understand
the delicate balance of the of the human
mind and here's the thing,
is he.
He went on,
he came on your show and told people
that here's a supplement they can take
and drink all they want and not get
drunk.
That gets people killed.
People said that and and use,
right though.
No,
he's not right.
What happens when you take Gludethyon if
you drunk?
Does it have any effect?
The body is a lot more complicated than
that.
It's a great example that I like to give
of this is the idea of oxidation and
antioxidants.
Oxidation causes aging.
It causes bad thing,
so take an antioxidant and that sounds
really simple,
but it's far more complex than that and
in fact it's so complicated.
That statement doesn't even mean
anything.
It's one of these things.
It's so wrong.
It's not even wrong.
As the saying goes,
you can't just take something that's
produced in your liver and counter
effect counteract the effects of
drinking alcohol.
There is no direct line from anything
you eat to any part of your body.
If you take,
if you're working out,
if you're trying to get buff and you
take a protein supplement,
you thinking,
hey,
protein coming in,
that's going to go to my muscles and
help them get strong.
That's something that is
incredibly wrong because it,
but it sounds so simplistically true.
It's not correct.
That's not the way the body works.
That's not the way the digestion system
works.
You cannot take something orally and
have it go as a direct line to any given
part of your body.
That's not the way our digestive system
and our blood works and when you say
that there's a supplement that can
prevent you from getting drunk,
your,
I'm sorry,
your against all reasonably established
science and you're trying to.
You're trying to make a buck off of
people potentially getting killed and I
had a huge problem with that to the
point that I had to turn the show off.
I was just getting mad driving in my car
and.
Okay,
keep going.
Sorry.
I think that that as someone with a huge
audience as you have,
I think you have more of a
responsibility to make sure that people
like that are called out on it.
If you can.
If you don't,
if he surprises you with it,
then say,
okay,
then I've got to get someone on next
week.
I got to go and get,
you know,
uh,
Steven Novella or someone like that.
Someone who is a promoter of science
based medicine to counteract that
because I think you could have left some
of your listeners with the impression
that hey,
they can now buy something and drink all
they want and then drive home safely.
Um,
okay.
I'm,
I'm looking online and immediately I
find articles that discussed glutathione
and it's,
it's role,
vital role in alcohol,
detoxification in the liver.
It binds to the toxin,
a civilized which s s,
w a subtle d high,
I don't know what else to tell to hide
as.
Thank you,
which is a byproduct is a product of
alcohol and is 10 to 30 times more toxic
than the alcohol itself.
Gludethyon then transfer.
Say it again after what asked to tell,
to hide,
to hide into compounds that can be
excreted.
Alcohol therefore depletes our store of
glutathione when depleted by excessive
alcohol consumption,
gludethyon becomes unavailable for
normal and natural antioxidant effects
leading to a host of health problems,
and this article is actually saying that
you should take glutathione when you
drink.
What you're talking about
about is reducing the effects of a
hangover,
getting over the hangover quickly.
It does not underscored,
does not prevent you from getting drunk
or in any way mitigate the,
the,
the
intox alcohol effects of the also it
doesn't diminish it or shrink it.
Like as if he said he does,
that's a believable one of his
statements were,
is that when you were drunk you could
take this stuff and it would,
uh,
it would bring you back to baseline
rather quick.
That is not true.
You can reduce the effects of a
hangover,
but you cannot prevent yourself from
getting.
Have you ever tried this?
Do you know this for a fact?
I've never tried his product.
No,
no,
no.
I mean it's not as product.
Luda is available pretty much
everywhere.
I mean you could buy it in health food
stores.
You can buy it online.
I have never tried anyone's product that
was intended as a
miracle drunk cure.
But I mean it would make sense though
that if alcohol and alcohol consumption
and the,
the,
the reaction that has in the body,
it's a chemical reaction that there
could be possibly something that could
counterbalance it or swing it in one way
or another.
Just like many other chemical reactions
and symbiotic reactions that we have to
things inside the body.
Now when you read something about this,
it seems like what you're,
your dispute is that he said that it
could diminish the effects of alcohol,
like while you're drunk and you're
saying that's not true.
It just helps with the hangover.
Yes.
If it helps with a hangover,
it's still really potent and pretty
interesting.
Um,
I would like to do a test on it.
I would like to see two people's blood
alcohol levels measured.
I think if you don't do that test.
Yeah,
you're,
you fucking saying something kind of
irresponsible.
Which he did.
I don't know if that test has been done
though.
Do you?
I have not searched the literature for
what if it has been done and he's right
then that would have.
That would have been all over the
literature.
What is someone who feels follows the
literature fairly closely?
I can tell you that it has not been all
over the literature that you can now
drink and not get drunk.
Well,
I mean maybe he was exaggerating.
I think he was exaggerating because he
was selling a product.
That's what it was
because he doesn't have a store.
He doesn't have anything.
I,
he's not.
When you say selling a product,
whereas he selling out of.
He doesn't have a store.
I don't really look,
this was the nine minutes of his
episode.
He was talking about what he sells.
If I'm wrong about that,
then I'm damn wrong about it.
And I'm surprised.
This is another thing is that is a thing
that's talking about a saving you from
being too drunk because of taking
glutathione before you drink.
Where are you seeing it?
Uh,
some fucking journal.
There's,
there's a,
there's a long look.
It's impossible to have a conversation
and Google things.
That's true.
But,
uh,
it's also one,
there's a,
a scientific article on reddit about
large amounts of glutathione,
uh,
have the potential to sober people up in
a very short time that we're researching
a chemical drug.
This is.
Listen,
man,
there's not,
he's not the only one that's talking
about this.
This is being discussed in many
different forms.
I don't know if he's right or wrong,
but I don't think you do either.
I would like to have him on with someone
who disputes it and find out,
but that's what I would recommend.
He's a very smart guy and he wasn't
saying that many outlandish things where
I'd have to pull them down like the
towers were destroyed by Tesla
technology.
That's not the same doctor.
Yeah,
he's a pretty reasonable guy.
He's a little bit out there.
You know?
He's kind of Wacky,
but literacy out there.
Oh,
he's out there on.
A
good thing to say is out there.
I don't know.
I'd have to listen to her to go over.
I liked the guy a lot.
I'm very biased when it comes to him.
He's a fun guy and he's very,
very smart,
but I'm looking at more than one thing
that's showing that you could advance
your sobriety,
but you could sober up quicker by taking
glutathione.
I don't know if they're right or he's
right or you're right,
but I don't know.
I don't know that you should be saying
that.
If you're not a doctor,
what if it turns out?
That is true.
I'm,
I'm not a doctor,
but I'm,
I'm a science writer and I,
I do google.
I do follow this stuff.
I've written on Google.
I did an episode.
Uh Oh,
probably three,
four months ago on a hangover.
What exactly is the cause of a hangover?
What's,
what's the nature of the toxicity?
He could use that information when it's
a really complicated subject.
It's an immunosuppressant.
The dehydration.
There's a lot of factors,
right?
Yeah.
And it basically comes down to a,
it's a depletion of glutathione in your
body.
Can't keep up with it.
Sounds like Dr Gordon's,
right?
No,
it's not as simple as that.
That's the thing is it's easy to sell
products by giving
an oversimplified description.
I'm telling you though,
you like,
you're,
you're pinning it on this guy.
He doesn't have a store.
Like you're saying,
he's selling products.
He's not,
he's not selling anything.
He,
he was certainly talking about a product
that's available.
Not his,
but he was,
he was talking to me about it even
before the podcast that he takes it.
Um,
I know,
uh,
Dave asprey from bulletproof exec.
He takes a glutathione but he never
brought up anything about it doing
anything for,
uh,
for alcohol.
Okay.
Well,
I,
I would just like to leave you with,
with the,
my opinion that sense listeners got the
impression that here's something that
they can take and drink.
All they want,
not get drunk is potentially lethal
advice.
Yes.
Who else got that information?
Who me.
I don't know if it's right either me and
the listeners got fed some information
that we don't know what's right.
I don't have any obligation other than
to talk to people.
My obligation is to ask questions if I'm
curious,
but in broadcasting this things,
I make the,
the,
the very clear distinction that I'm not
an expert.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about when I'm talking about things like
health and medicine and,
but I'm fascinating.
So if I'm talking to someone and they're
an expert and they bring up something
that I didn't prepare for,
I'm going to ask him questions about it.
And you know,
I will say I wish I knew if you're full
of shit,
but that's about as good as I could do.
The reason I had the reason I initially
did this episode,
excuse me five years ago,
about celebrities who promote harmful
pseudoscience is because when you have a
large audience,
I believe you do have an obligation to
not give harmful information.
But I'm not giving it.
I don't think for a minute that you've
ever knowingly given any harmful
information.
I'm not accusing you of anything at all.
But if it has been given by one of your
guests and you are in the position of
having to say,
that sounds too good to be true.
I wish I was.
I wish I knew enough to call you out on
your bullshit.
Um,
it seems to me like a reasonable step to
follow that up with would have been to
find out with
get somebody on who can,
who can,
uh,
who can address the other side of that
question.
Perhaps I can turn this around on you
and say it would be so easy for.
You have to research all those different
things on that list that you accused me
of many of them,
which are not true at all and never have
been true,
but yet you printed them.
I did.
So why did you do that?
If you're a man of science information,
would you possibly have had?
Because I was using the Internet in 2008
and I look,
look every,
every,
probably three,
four months or so.
I do an episode that is nothing but
corrections,
corrections of things I've been wrong
about in the past.
I think that's a great plan.
I think it's great that I do that.
I want to continue doing it.
I will need more things to be wrong
about so I can produce.
Those episodes were often,
but what you vote is very specific and
what I want and what I came here today
to do was to find out which of those are
wrong and so that I will correct them.
Yeah,
but even this one thing you just said he
wasn't selling it,
but you got that wrong,
but you're saying that he was selling.
That wasn't on my show.
I was listening to this show it wrong
and you're saying it's
true and so now you're sending it out to
the road that this guy sells a product.
He doesn't.
You're doing the exact same thing that
you're blaming joe for.
No,
I'm not.
I,
I.
You are though.
You're saying this guy sells something
when he doesn't.
Yeah.
You said that's hardly the salient
point.
The salient point is that information is
being given that could potentially kill
people.
Right,
but your information
as a medical expert,
which he is under the guise of selling a
product which is erroneous.
Okay,
but I've.
I've also said that I don't know whether
it's his store,
someone else's store,
but it's a product that he's talking
about that's the salient point.
Whether it's his store,
someone else's store doesn't really make
a lick of difference compared to the
fact that it's potentially
saying that he doesn't believe in it or
that if he believes in it he's wrong and
when he's saying is that he uses it,
he doesn't sell it.
And you're saying that he's saying that
because he sells it.
That was very specific.
You had taken this very cynical approach
to why he's disseminating this
information.
Fair enough,
and,
and I'm,
I'm right now if I said that I was wrong
on this,
sweetie,
you,
and that's to say that these aren't dumb
people.
They can't realize that they're drunk
and they're taking a pill and they're
going to go,
well,
I said,
I said to him why I was.
That sounds like horse shit.
You did.
You did,
but I don't know.
I mean,
he's a fucking smart guy.
Like I,
I know for a fact that that guy has
helped a lot of people with traumatic
brain injury.
That's a different subject,
but he's a doctor.
He's a legit scientist and a doctor.
I mean he's a really brilliant guy.
So when he talks to me about the issues
with a pituitary gland and impacts and
his expertise on the human mind,
that relates to me that he has a very
vast understanding of the human body
itself.
When he tells me something like this and
then I started reading that,
there's more than one different article
that sort of confirms what he's saying.
I don't know if you're right.
You might've gotten harsh on my friend
Dr Gordon for no reason,
I think.
I think it's a very good reason.
I.
If if he's giving,
he's giving advice that's potentially
killing people.
I think that's a very good reason to err
on the side of this information should
be.
Should be checked.
That's true,
but if you're so dumb that you're just
just pound in alcohol and trusting the
glutathione is going to do it,
it's going to kill you.
That's a Darwin award winner.
If you're using spotify on to fucking
know he's not saying drink all you want
and you're going to be fine.
I mean,
he never said that.
He never said there's no risk involved.
What he was saying is it can help you
get sober quicker.
I don't know if he's right,
but I don't think you do either.
That's not what I heard.
What you.
What did you hear?
I heard him say you can drink and not
get drunk.
We can listen to it on the Internet.
See if you could pull it up.
So you give pull.
If there's a very small sample that we
could find.
Yeah,
I think we're kind of splitting hairs
here.
I could see why you'd be upset and I
could see why you would think that I
have the responsibility to call someone
out.
I would have to be the expert on a
million different things and then I
would have to have people on and have
people counteract them and have people
go back and forth and debates and that's
all well and good in the real world.
If you can organize those debates and if
you get those people together,
but for the most part I'm lucky to get
someone to sit down once.
I'm lucky to get someone who can fit
into a times that I have and have them
on the show and I just want to have a
conversation with them.
I didn't have any idea that God was
going to bring up glutathione.
In fact,
we wanted to highlight his work on
traumatic brain injury because there's a
big issue with mixed martial arts these
days and the big issue is there's
twofold.
One traumatic brain injury and to the
depletion of testosterone because of
traumatic brain injury.
It's been shown in people that have come
back from war and suffered a head
injuries and it's been shown from boxers
and people that have sustained long term
even subconcussive impacts to the head
that the pituitary gland gets fucked up
and he's trying to sort of spread this
information and keep fighters from
taking testosterone to counteract that
and then competing to and continuing to
compete,
continuing to damage the brain.
And it's an issue in mixed martial arts
and it's one of the reasons why I had
him on because he's a,
he's a brilliant guy.
And um,
he is very troubled by this idea that
we're going to put a bandaid on
traumatic brain injury by giving these
guys testosterone use exemptions.
He thinks it's wrong.
He thinks if your body is producing less
testosterone because of impacts,
you shouldn't give it testosterone and
continue receiving impacts.
That was the whole premise for him
coming on the show in the first place.
So for me,
I felt like I,
um,
he's the smartest person I know in
regards to this particular subject.
So I felt it was kind of important to
discuss it with them.
I have no idea that's glutathione shit
was going to come up with,
but here's what he said.
We're going to pick up after you drink
and you take them.
What is the,
what is it?
Unbelievable gludethyon pull that thing
closer to your face so people hear you
better.
Glutathione,
glutathione and that.
That helps your liver when you drink
alcohol.
Well,
it helps you with just about anything
that delivers responsible for I'm
digesting or metabolizing.
As you metabolize certain drugs,
chemicals and so forth.
The liver uses up its ability to
continue the process so it spills over
into the blood and that's how you get a,
you know,
drunk because your liver can only deal
with a certain amount,
so if you replenish or replace the
glutathione in the liver,
you get an incredible benefits of it.
Not only does it help with metabolism,
but it's an incredible antioxidant for
the brain and for the eyes and for the
heart.
What is it made out of a.
it's three amino acids that are
together.
It's in our body,
but we don't have enough of it to really
generate the metabolism that we needed
for drinking and where do they get that?
Where do they get glutathione,
because I know Dave asprey's really into
that stuff too.
Version of it's manufactured,
but how do they make it?
What is a three amino acids that they
put together and the products that we
interact with?
Our HRA,
it's a delivery technology.
We're wrap the vitamins or you wrap the
supplement in a what's called a,
which is like a cell wall,
so from lecithin is from soy and it
protects whatever it is that you're
ingesting.
A lot of the things that you take,
like I think I shared with you,
if you take a thousand milligrams of
vitamin C by mouth,
you only absorb 19 percent.
The rest of it is destroyed by the acid
in the stomach,
but if you wrap it in this protection
called the light bulbs home,
you'll be able to absorb 93 percent.
So taking something like Glutathione,
which normally when you take it in in
its natural form,
it's destroyed.
Most of it is destroyed and then
absorbed,
then remanufactured in the blood,
but if you wrap it in this protective
outer coating,
a Lyposomal,
you can absorb it more readily and their
effects are unbelievably positive.
For instance,
a gentleman who went out drinking three
high balls and five shots of Tequila
went home and subsequently was very
dizzy,
nauseous.
He forgot that I gave them a sample of a
this glutathione and he's used four
puffs under the tongue,
held it for 30 seconds,
and then 30 minutes later,
clear Isabelle woke up the next day,
went out partying again.
Couldn't get drunk.
Wow.
That sounds like nonsense.
It isn't.
So I was smart enough to call you on
your bullshit.
Talk to my office,
Aaron.
Okay.
Everything sounds crazy.
Maybe that guy will cut her off right
there.
Maybe when I was actually at the
beginning of the podcast,
I remember that was about where I got
mad and that was right in.
Um,
I don't buy the.
He says he couldn't get drunk the next
day.
That's very anecdotal though.
And what he was saying was just hard
science.
What a good doctor is not going to go
and tell people anecdotes like you can
take this product and not get drunk.
I agree,
and maybe he was nervous being on a
podcast.
You probably shouldn't have said it.
No Man,
a million people.
Plus they're going to listen to it.
However,
what he said was all hard science.
What he said was,
okay,
here are the things he said that led me
to believe that it was his product at
least obviously here where you would
watch it.
Again,
it wasn't as product.
He wasn't selling.
He said,
he said,
I gave him the supplement and you said,
here's the delivery thing that we're
working on,
so maybe I misinterpreted that.
Let me tell you something about this
guy.
He's a very generous guy and he gives
people the vitamins all the time.
He's like,
here,
try this out.
This has been taken.
This is an incredible amino acid.
It's Baba Baba grapeseed and he's just
a.
He gives things out to people.
Okay,
here's the he,
he.
He said,
it has all of these amazing effects in
your heart,
your brain,
your eyes,
antioxidants,
and he's using language like
extraordinary and amazing and in my
experience,
in my experience,
dealing with many quacks of many
different duck species.
If it looks on quacks like when it's
usually a quack and he was using very
quack like language and making very
quick points.
I don't know anybody accused,
you could accuse him of hyperbole,
but what he's saying is essentially hard
science about the Lyposomal,
the digesting of nutrients using the
lyposomal method as opposed to just
normally being broken down by stomach
acids.
All the things he's saying.
It's not that ridiculous.
Yeah,
I mean,
when you.
If you usually take something,
if I.
If you take some kind of an enzyme or
something in your mouth,
your saliva is going to start breaking
it down into their constituent amino
acids right away and you're right.
It's what he said was right.
It's not going to get used as
glutathione in your body.
Those amino acids are going to go their
separate ways and become used for
whatever else your body actually is
looking for.
At the time,
I don't know about his particular
delivery method that he's talking about,
but when he says it's not his
guaranteed,
I don't know about this stuff,
the particular delivery method he's
talking about,
but when he says,
you can take a thousand milligrams of
vitamin C and your body's going to
absorb 93 percent of it,
that's in my experience medically
nonsensical and your body doesn't need
that much.
Will your body doesn't use that 93
percent of what though?
What are the vitamin C you took in your
thousand,
but what if it's a small amount?
If he's saying that your body absorbs 93
percent of vitamin C's,
not saying that you need a thousand
milligrams in your body absorbs 93
percent.
What he's saying that if you deliver it
in a lyposomal form,
you get a 93 percent bioavailability.
He's not giving a specific number that
you should take.
He was saying that if you take vitamin
C,
most of it gets destroyed unless you use
it Lyposomal,
which I think is correct,
but your body doesn't have any use for
93 percent of a thousand milligrams of
vitamin C.
He didn't say that.
He didn't say you need a thousand
milligrams and then 93 percent of it is
absorbed.
What he said is if you take it light but
Somali,
it's a higher rate of vial availability
and it's up to 93 percent.
He didn't say you have to take 100
milligrams.
Do you think she was implying that it's
better to have a dosage?
She was trying to say that it's better
to have lyposomal vitamin C because it's
more bioavailable.
That's all hard sciences.
I was a better.
If it's going to give you more than you
can use,
how is it better?
No,
you're adding that.
He didn't say that you have to have a
thousand milligrams.
What he said is that if you take it,
19 percent is going to get absorbed.
You'd take it through the traditional
method.
If you take it light,
so molly,
then you get 93 percent absorption.
He didn't give you a dose it.
He wasn't saying he wasn't suggesting or
implying that that's them to be wrong.
Siren.
This is not.
This is not cool.
Look,
I'm just.
I'm just saying it looks and quacks like
a duck generous,
which you're saying is disingenuous
because that's not what he's saying.
What what he's saying there was that the
bioavailability of lipel symbol
nutrients is better and that's true.
You're saying that he's saying a
thousand milligrams in Europe.
Point of contention is you don't need a
thousand milligrams.
He never said you need a thousand
milligrams of Lyposomal vitamin C.
all he said was that when you take
vitamin C,
lipel stumbling.
Your body absorbs it better.
Whether it says what it's really 93
percent.
Okay.
Yeah,
it is.
Look at this.
Fuck they're saying on a live and labs
lyposomal science.
I'm saying a bioavailability,
a vial of bioavailability of 98 percent.
There's another one that says over 90
percent.
So what he's saying is true.
What he's saying is fact,
and you're.
You're shitting on it because you don't
want them to be right about what I think
you're correct about is this,
this idea,
this anecdotal story of a guy,
you know,
taking this stuff,
feeling better 30 minutes later and then
the next day couldn't get drunk.
That sounds like bullshit to me too,
but all that other stuff that he said,
that's all science.
I'm shitting on anyone who is selling
snake oil.
Basically come on pitching snake oil to
be bought or suggesting that that buying
supplements and things that you don't
need is a good way to spend your money.
But wait a minute.
If someone likes to drink isn't a smart
thing to take glutathione after you
drank to to shorten your hangover.
Isn't that effective?
I would have to look at the research
before I would tell you
you said it.
You said it before you said that it.
It aids in reducing hangover.
Okay.
Yeah.
So it.
So why wouldn't you take that?
You're saying that he's selling
something that you don't need.
It's not as simple as that,
but wait a minute.
Wait.
None of these issues are as simple as
saying it is,
but uh,
you're,
you're saying that you take glutathione
when you're hung over and it reduces the
length of your hangover.
He saying,
take glutathione.
You're saying saying to take glutathione
is unnecessarily.
You're saying that you don't need it
when needed.
You don't need nutrients.
You could live on cheeseburgers and get
to be fucking 60 years old.
Just eating shitty food.
That doesn't mean it doesn't mean your
life isn't enhanced by raw vegetables
and nutrients and having a balanced
diet.
You,
you saying that you don't need
glutathione is pretty ridiculous.
If you can get glutathione into your
liver,
you will,
your hangover will be reduced.
So why don't you either.
This method of taking a supplement will
get glutathione into your liver is
something that I don't know and I would
have to look at the research before I
would tell you that you're already in.
I will tell you being wrong,
I'm,
I'm accusing him being wrong,
that you can take a product and not get
drunk after trying,
trying to get drunk and not able to get
drunk.
I'm saying that that's wrong and it
borders on being really,
really unethical.
He wrong.
We agree on that,
but you've set up all sorts of Straw man
arguments for why he did it and what
he's doing and what he's saying and the
bioavailability of vitamin C in those
all fall under the fall apart under
scrutiny,
so let's have him come on and correct it
this time to come on and debate you.
He doesn't know you wouldn't get it.
I'd get I'd get someone who knows the
business.
He said,
look,
he's a silly guy and sometimes he might
speak in hyperbole,
but what he's saying that you corrected
your wrong about about bio availability.
You attributed him to this erroneous
number of a thousand milligrams.
He didn't say that.
He did not.
Did you want to play?
Let's play it again.
Let's play again.
The light bulbs,
Samo,
we don't need to play.
If you take a thousand milligrams of
vitamin C and ut and a and you take it
Lyposomal,
you'll absorb 93
and it's not what he said.
What he said was,
if you take a thousand milligrams of
vitamin C,
your body only absorbs 19 percent,
and he said,
if you take vitamin C,
Lipids Soumala,
your body absorbs a giant amount of it.
He said 19 percent and 93 percent.
That's what he said.
He didn't say,
you know,
you're saying you don't need that much
vitamin C and that's why he's wrong,
but high levels of vitamin C,
that's debatable as well because high
levels of vitamin C have been shown to
be potent antioxidants that could
prevent against certain types of
diseases.
A lot of people think it boosts your
immune system.
It helps fight off various pathogens.
There's a lot of research hard data that
shows that high levels of vitamin C is
probably pretty good for you.
In my research,
all of that has turned out to be
nonsense.
Your research on vitamin C is extensive?
Yes.
What's your research on vitamin C?
God,
I can look up my episode for you.
I mean,
it was a few years ago.
We talked mostly about it.
It was invented by a course linus
pauling,
who by this time in his career was
something of a crank and came up with
this notion that vitamin,
Mega dosing would cure cancer,
and he wrote the book called
can't remember the name of his book,
but that's essentially what started off
the whole vitamin and supplement
movement that still exists very strongly
to this day.
And what we have found by testing is
that vitamin C does not significantly
affect cancer.
The length or duration or severity of a
cold,
etc. Etc.
All of thEse things that we take it for,
this caused a great rift between him and
science and he spent most of the rest of
his career,
which was fairly short because he was
quite elderly by that time.
Uh,
basically widening that rift and
debating with,
uh,
with the medical profession and trying
to defend his vitamin mega dosing idea.
And what you'll find now,
I mean this is pretty much everywhere in
recent scientific literature,
is the idea that vitamins really don't
do anything for you because very few
people have vitamin deficiencies and you
still have health
list evidence demonstrating that vitamin
c's,
anticancer properties that high levels
of vitamin c kills cancer.
This is the national institute of health
and read the whole thing.
I bet you anything that's talked about
in vitro,
in vitro or ivy you mean?
You mean in vitro means if you put
something in a petri dish and you put
some cells in there and you pour
something in it and it kills the cells
that's in vitro.
It's got very little to do with
institute,
which has means actually doing some
tests in your body.
So
the ivc,
is that what they would call it?
High dose ivc.
Is that in vitro?
No,
it would just be written out in vitro.
it's not saying that saying high dose
ivc,
a nontoxic chemotherapeutic agent that
can be given in conjunction with
conventional cancer treatments based on
the work of several vitamin c pioneers.
Before Dr. Jordan was able to prove that
vitamin c was selectively toxic to
cancer cells,
if given intravenously.
This research has recently reproduced
and published by Dr. Mark Levine at the
national institute of health.
So meaning that it's the bioavailability
is at its highest because it's
intravenously introduced,
meaning that what he was saying about
the bioavailability,
bioavailability because of lyposomal
science,
that would also be a higher absorption
rate than eating it normally.
So what he's saying is that what this
article is saying is that there's
benefit to taking high level of vitamin
c.
I look,
I don't have that article in front of
me,
but I will tell you in my experience
that you can find an article making any
point you want to very easily because
about anything and,
but does having,
having researched this extensively and
being very familiar
with,
um,
with science writers and science
journalist in virtually every field,
I can tell you that the current thinking
is not that vitamin c has any beneficial
effect on cancer.
So you are no idea what this article is
that you're looking at.
I think it's complicated,
man.
You know,
I think there's a,
there's a lot of work being done that
shows that there are benefits to taking
in nutrients.
There's a,
there was a study transfer,
the different various vitamins
supplementing various vitamins.
Um,
there was uh,
an interesting one that I'm looking at
right now that we're talking about the,
um,
the prevention of shit.
I'll try to find it,
but I didn't see know those,
um,
here's one,
uh,
infectious illness prevention and this
is a,
a ncbi website.
It's a national health institute,
national institute for health,
mood and stress cognition,
and they've shown that it's actually
that you could take high level that
vitamin c and different antioxidants and
multivitamins had been shown to decrease
juvenile delinquency.
Like I said,
you can find an article.
what did you search for it,
by the way?
What was your search term?
I don't remember.
Benefits of vitamin c suck dick vitamins
through that all together.
you know,
man,
I,
I see where you're going with all this
and I see your point of view.
You're a no nonsense guy and I,
I agree with you for the most part.
And I think that,
uh,
you know,
in the case of Dr. Gordon and his
description was probably rather
unfortunate that he decided to give that
anecdotal story along with this very
interesting aspect of researching
nutrition fair assessment.
I'll,
I'll agree with that.
It's not a,
it would never make me angry enough to
shut it off and yell at them and your
descriptions of even what he said and
the event is off,
you know,
and I think that's from this hard
stance,
no nonsense approach you have.
And I don't blame you if you look in the
world that we live in,
it's filled with bullshit and a no
nonsense guy gets fucking tired of
dealing with bullshit at a,
on a regular basis all day long.
And I think you're a bit knee jerk and
your reactions,
their fellow.
Okay,
they,
you're certainly not the only person to
have said that.
Well,
you used to believe that big foot five
years ago may lighten up.
Here's the thing with the thing,
the best definition of skepticism is the
intersection of science education and
consumer protection.
If people are have better science
literacy,
they are less likely to take advantage
of products that are worthless.
Okay.
That is a way of looking at it that it
aids in consumer protection.
That is my motivation.
I believe that information,
it aids in consumer protection,
all the information,
the eventually.
Right now we're dealing with this
rudimentary sort of a way of
assimilating it and distributing it and
I think ultimately all the bullshit that
we're dealing with in this world will
stop to to be valid.
I think what we're dealing with right
now is like we google things when they.
When we have an answer about something
and then one day we're going to have an
unstoppable like base of knowledge and I
think that it's probably sooner than
later,
but right now when we do have this,
these discrepancies and these,
these issues,
any gray area,
anywhere that you're wrong and you take
this hard stance,
this hard no nonsense stance,
it actually does more harm than it does
good because if we could show that
you're wrong than even though it's not,
your message is correct.
I agree with your message has set it at
the time and he's my friend.
I wish I could call you out on your
bullshit.
I wished I could because I know him and
he's kind of crazy,
but you saying all those things
diminishes your initial point because
your initial point was very valid.
He was being irresponsible in saying
that you could take this stuff and not
get drunk.
It seems ridiculous.
He shouldn't have told that anecdote
story,
but you shouldn't have insisted that he
had said a thousand milligrams and that
is 93 percent bioavailability and then
you're trying to find some way that he's
wrong.
So you're going,
well,
why do you need that much?
And he didn't say that.
Well,
he's trying to sell this stuff.
He's not selling shit.
He doesn't have a store.
He's not selling a god damn thing.
Okay,
we'll agree to disagree on whether he
said that,
oh,
we played,
we played it,
we played it back and I heard.
But then again,
you hear it again,
his thousand milligrams and you've given
me some great advice as far as a health
and fitness and exercise and all sorts
of kudos.
Gouda.
Had a couple of minutes.
The whole thing.
Every conversation though.
I know I forgot something.
I know it's good ahead.
Tell them about him and shit helps your
liver after you drank and you this good
head.
What is this?
What is it?
Unbelievable.
Gludethyon no,
but he goes go a little bit of nuance
specifically
gludethyon and that would.
And the products that we interact with
our,
a delivery technology,
we're um,
you wrap the vitamins or you wrap the
supplement in a what's called a
liposome,
which is like a cell wall.
So from lecithin is from soy and it
protects whatever it is that you're
ingesting.
A lot of the things that you take,
like I think I shared with you,
if you take a thousand milligrams of
vitamin c by mouth,
you only absorb 19 percent.
The rest of it is destroyed by the acid
that's in the stomach.
But if you wrap it in this protection
called the lyposomal,
you'll be able to absorb 93 percent.
So taking something like glutathione,
which
exactly he didn't say,
you take a thousand milligrams of
vitamin c.
He said if you do,
you absorb 93 percent.
If you take.
He's just giving numbers.
I'm saying if you take a thousand
milligrams of vitamin c,
he's not recommending that as a dose.
He's saying if you do,
your body absorbs 19 percent.
That's true.
He's saying if you wrap it in a
lyposomal structure,
your body absorbs 93 percent.
I'm kind of stunned on what you're
saying.
I got wrong.
I said he said a thousand milligrams of
vitamin c and you'll absorb 93 percent
of what you said wrong in was he's
telling you to take a thousand.
He wasn't telling you to take anything.
What he's saying is if you take a
thousand milligrams of vitamin c,
your body will only absorb 19 percent.
If you wrap it in this lyposomal
structure,
your body will absorb 93 percent.
I know he's not recommending that as a
daily allowance.
He's not telling you to take it.
You're trying to find a way to be right
here.
I think I'm repeating exactly what you
just said.
I'm just kind of stunned at that.
You're pointing out what I said was
wrong.
I said,
I mean this,
this is.
This is kind of deteriorating and it's
not entertainment quality here.
No,
no.
Explaining where you air in the way you
cast judgment and that you're.
You're incorrect about what he was
saying,
but you were your main point.
Where he's wrong is why do you need that
much vitamin c in the first place?
What's the big deal,
but this lyposomal thing,
you were trying to diminish him.
You're trying to find ways to diminish
his point,
but he's correct.
All he gave me,
he gave you a number.
If he didn't give you a number of a
thousand milligrams would have.
He said 100 milligrams.
What have you said?
Five hundred milligrams.
this point was your body.
He came up with a number for a point of
reference,
but his point was,
your body only absorbs 19 percent.
He said then if yoU take it lyposomal,
your body absorbs 93 percent.
He didn't mean that you have to take a
thousand milligrams.
He doesn't tell you to take a thousand
milligrams.
He just gave you a point of reference
for explaining the bioavailability of
lipos somo products as opposed to the
standard form of
desk.
Justin,
can I just summarize my position and we
can move on just in two points.
Point number one is he used very quack
like language throughout the nine
minutes that I listened to saying it's
amazing,
and I became.
Yeah,
sweetie.
Yes.
Say which?
Which made me very skeptical of his
motivations and of the quality of his
information.
Um,
number two,
you do not need to take a thousand
milligrams of vitamin c.
He didn't say you do this.
This is not a strong man.
This is right.
This is summarizing my point.
My point right now,
his point,
my point is that you do not need to take
doses of any doses of vitamins or other
supplements unless you're one of the
rare people who for some reason it has a
vitamin deficiency,
which is,
you know,
you need to be pretty sick or have some
problem to have any need for any that
you were criticizing him for saying that
you need a thousand milligrams,
which is in fact not what he said.
I don't.
I.
Okay.
I don't think he would have said that
unless he was trying to imply or suggest
that he's going to take vitamin c.
I'm sure he thinks it's a good thing to
take.
Vitamin c is a matter of fact.
That's the reason why people don't get
scurvy.
Right?
Take vitamin c is good for you.
It keeps that from happening.
If you go on a long boat trip with a
bunch of assholes who were eating dried
meat,
take your vitamins.
Say,
look,
there's nothing wrong with vitamin c,
but what he's saying is he gave a point
of reference.
He started with a thousand milligrams.
If you take that,
he.
It's a figure of speech.
You will absorb 19 percent if you take
it liable.
So emily,
you absorb 93 percent.
We're beating a dead horse.
You're wrong.
Here
I,
I am flabbergasted that you're saying
I'm wrong,
but let's just move on.
I mean this is just going around in
circles.
This is silly,
but it's,
it's,
it's highlighting the way you think and
the way one of the things about the way
you think is this desire to be right and
you have a very strong desire to win.
You're criticizing him to be right and I
think you're wrong and I think you're
wrong about a couple of things.
You're wrong about your initial
description of the way he described
things as wrong and you don't like the
way he used adjectives or hyperbole and
you said that's what I'm talking about.
Okay,
that's not exactly what you're talking
type of language was what was what I was
real good point is that he said that you
could not get drunk or that his friend
wasn't drunk,
but that's a really good point.
That sounds like nonsense to me still
sounds like nonsense.
I think that's a,
I think he exaggerated or I think he
told an anecdotal story of someone who's
bullshitting him.
Unfortunately,
those nights where you drink and drink
and drink and you just can't get drunk,
you've had this experience fucked up.
What I'm saying is,
man,
you're a hard line dude.
You don't smoke any weed at all.
Do you know?
There you go.
That's what you need.
You need a little cooky and a massage.
Here we get a thai massage.
Pull your arms back to walk in your
back.
Relax,
man.
You.
There's,
there's,
there's a lot of merit in what you're
doing and there's a lot of merit and
what you're saying.
I understand your arguments for this
hard stance.
I totally understand it,
but I also think that sometimes
diminishes your actual point,
which can many times be very valid.
Such as,
well,
this,
this whole shit.
We're doing this dance about vitamin c.
Why do you think he brought it up?
Why do you think?
You talked about wanting to talk about
glutathione.
He wanted to talk about,
if you listen to the whole podcast,
he talks about a variety of different
ways that we can improve our health and
things to avoid,
especially head impacts and he,
you know,
it goes into depth.
He's a very,
he's a very interesting and very
charitable guy.
You're not a bad guy at all.
So I was confused as to I could see how
you would get upset that statement,
absolutely.
But All that other stuff leading up to
the statement that sort of flavor the
statement and make it even worse and
grander turned out to not be true
anytime.
Anytime you're suggesting selling,
promoting miraculously easy solutions to
complicated problems that should raise a
huge red flag.
And all of the language he was using
suggested a miraculously easy solution.
Words like the words he was using,
the uh,
being.
Um,
I think he actually,
in his defense,
he used a lot of those words just to
describe it's a fax as an antioxidant,
which is pretty much universally
accepted online.
Um,
well.
But what effects is an antioxidant?
It's a strong antioxidant.
what has,
what has been what the current state of
antIoxidant research is that
supplementation has no benefit.
The antioxidants that you get from your
normal diet are more than enough that
your body can,
will need to use supplementation,
has no benefit.
Oh,
how did they can lighten me?
How do they test to see the benefit of
antioxidants and antioxidants?
A couple minutes.
This goes to the whole
question of oxidation versus
antioxidant.
Sounds like it's a really simple
question.
Good versus bad.
Oxidation is part of so many different
parts of your metabolism.
Converting the energy and sell to
converting your chemical energy and sell
to Connecticut injured.
That's.
That's oxidation.
You can't just simply say antioxidants,
good oxidation,
bad.
It's not as simple as that.
Okay,
but no one's saying what you're saying
is that what you're saying is
antioxidants have no benefit.
If you take them as a supplement,
supplementation of antioxidants has been
found to have no benefit.
Where is that?
Is that published somewhere?
If you google that sentence,
I'm sure you'll find it supplementation
of antioxidants,
but how do they know the difference
between taking it with the.
The benefits of taking it with food and
the benefits of taking it as a
supplement.
Well,
because we can chemically measure what's
in the food,
we can chemically measure what's in a
supplement.
We know how much your body uses and
the number of tests that have been done
are all going to use different
methodologies and I'm sorry I did not
memorize.
I'm honestly,
I can't tell you.
I'm honestly curious.
What I do as a science writer is
summarize the available research,
so what?
This is what I'm confused about you.
if you are taking it in food,
there's a benefit from it.
The amount of oxidation that you get
into normal diet.
Yes.
If you don't eat a normal diet,
then I presume that if you were going on
a starvation diet or something,
then I suppose you'd probably want to
take a multivitamin.
You at least get your vitamins.
You wouldn't be getting anything else
that you'd need,
but you'd be getting vitamins.
I suppose the same is true of just about
any supplement if you're going to starve
yourself,
but the best,
the best advice of all is to simply eat
a normal healthy diet because those
things,
those,
those aspects of nutrition or available
in that normal healthy diet and their
bio available,
there's,
you know,
there's six basic things that you get in
food.
Number one is water.
Number two is amino acids.
A number three is carbohydrates,
sugar,
um,
number four is fats and five.
Number six,
what am I missing here?
Oh,
fives,
vitamins and minerals.
So these are all the different classes
of things that you need and any normal
healthy diet has all of those that your
body is going to use because actually
you need quite tiny amounts of all of
those things.
Your body actually uses very tiny
amounts.
Any normal diet,
the reason you poop and pee is because
you ate more than you needed.
Supplementation is trying to pour water
on a bucket that's already overflowing.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
The reason you poop ps,
not because he ate,
drank more than you needed,
you're going to poop and pee if you just
drink the exact right amount too.
You can poop and pee all the way to
starvation.
No,
you can't.
You'll stop pooping if you stop eating.
If you keep drinking water when the
water passes through your body,
it's not because you drank too much
water.
You drink.
If you drink a glass of water,
okay,
and that water goes through is exactly
what your body needed in a few hours,
you're gonna need it as a waste
eliminator.
Your kidneys are going to continue
producing urine until there is till you
dehydrate until you're dehydrated,
but there's not a balancing act where
you can hit the certain sweet spot where
you eat exactly what you need or drink
exactly what you need.
Look,
I'm not talking about finding a sweet
spot.
What I'm saying,
pooping and peeing is because you ate
too much,
drank too much.
That's not true.
You're taking my words to literally.
I will.
That's a very literal statement,
isn't it?
I mean,
come on.
That's ridiculous.
Medical statement.
A doctor would listen to that
medical statement.
What are you saying that what I'm saying
is supplementation of any of these
things is pouring water on a bucket
that's already over full.
You don't need more sugar than your body
is going to use.
You don't need more minerals than your
body is going to use.
You don't need more vitamins than your
body's going to use.
Anything that you eat of those that is
more than you're gonna use is going to
be treated from your body somehow or
other,
sooner or later.
That makes sense.
That's what I'm saying.
Okay.
I'm,
uh,
I would,
I would love to know what studies they
did on antioxidants and what they know,
the benefits of.
I mean,
they absolutely have measured the
benefits of it from food,
the individual nutrients and
antioxidants and what sort of effect
they have on the human body.
Um,
and what I'd really be curious to find
out what studies disproved that or prove
that.
Okay.
Here,
if you're on google right now,
google scup,
toyed antioxidant.
Not going to read your stuff.
Silly.
I'm going to,
if I'm going to google stuff,
I'm going to google people that disagree
with you,
but if there's a lot of people that do
agree with you,
in all fairness online,
if if you.
If you.
If you want to find out if you want to
ask what my sources were,
where I got the information,
and that's where you'll find it,
the references at the bottom of the
episode.
I just wonder what the motivation of
these studies were,
what,
what the protocol was,
and there's a lot of variables like this
new study that came out that said case
closed multivitamin.
Researchers came out and said that
multivitamins don't work well if you
know what the study was,
that they actually studied the,
the,
the protocol that they used and what
they actually tried to do.
It's kind of irresponsible statement to
say vitamins don't work.
case closed.
What they did was they gave
multivitamins these hard multivitamins
to physicians over age 65 and they
showed no improvement in cognitive
decline,
so they took people that were already
declining.
They gave him vitamins that were these
hard fucking synthetic vitamins and they
showed no,
no decline,
no,
no ceasing in the climbing of their
cognitive function.
another one,
high dose multivitamins had no effect on
the progression of heart disease and
heart attack survivors.
So these people are already fucked.
they already had a heart attack.
They give them high levels of these.
Again,
synthetic multivitamins,
these compressed pill form,
you know,
centrum one a day,
jammies that nobody digests,
and then another one,
the third study,
which actually is fairly positive
concludes that limited evidence supports
any benefit from vitamin and mineral
supplementation for the prevention of
cancer or cardiovascular disease.
two trials found a small borderline
significant benefit from multivitamins,
supplements on cancer in men only and no
effect on cardiovascular disease.
So that's a small barely measurable
effect from these shitty synthetic
vitamins on people who are fuCked.
People who are already sick,
people,
their bodies are already dying.
Like to say that vitamins don't work
based on those three components is a
ridiculous.
Well,
you know,
a really unfortunate aspect of the world
of science reporting.
Something that I've come to learn over
and over and over again,
and it's,
it's pretty depressing is how news makes
it from the lab into,
onto people's computers or gotcha aspect
of the title,
right?
Yeah.
The fact is that universities were so
much research has done,
they have pr departments and they are
responsible for keeping attention on
this university,
keeping,
keeping the money flowing,
and the pr department at a university is
going to spin what they see as the most
reportable aspect of the research being
done.
They send out the press release and then
the press does exactly the same thing.
They look at it and look for the most
reportable aspect of this and it's
often,
um,
often it's completely wrong by the time
it gets to the presses because they'll
report the sensational aspect of it.
And what you'll often see,
I follow a lot of science writers who do
this a lot,
is they,
they kind of reverse engineer these
headlines that have become so prominent.
And it's always.
Some scientists find that this will kill
you.
Scientists find that this is a miracle
cure.
And when you reverse engineer those
headlines and go back and look at the
original research that was done,
you'll find often it said exactly the
opposite of what the headline says.
It's really difficult to come up with,
um,
kind of a journeyman's interpretation of
sCience news by reading,
by reading mass media.
Yeah.
They did publish the study though.
The title of this study is enough,
is enough,
stop wasting money on vitamin and
mineral supplements.
And this is the title of the article
that was released.
I think they took an inflammatory
position that I don't think it's
supported by the evidence and the
research that they presented.
And it's very short sighted.
There's many,
many aspects to a to health.
And when you're dealing with someone who
is already really fucking sick,
which is all three of the people that
they described that they tested these
things on all groups of people,
you know,
you're,
you're dealing with a mean to try to
like the rate of decline in people that
have alzheimer's and the rate of decline
of people with cognitive decline.
We don'T have anything that's going to
stop that.
Like what makes you thiNk the vitamins
are going to stop it because the
vitamins don't stop it.
Be things that would be benefIcial for
health are not stopping something that
we've never been able to stop.
That seems preposterous to say vitamins
don't work based on that evidence.
It seems to me like this is something
that was a predetermined conclusion or
the most inflammatory response,
wHich we're talking about it.
So it's effective in that sense.
Sure.
Yeah.
So 10 minutes.
We're almost out.
We turn into a pumpkin at three hours
in,
um,
well,
there,
there is a really unfortunate word and
it's consensus and the word consensus.
I describe it as unfortunate because it
has a very different meaning in popular
usage than it has in scientific fields.
In scientific fields.
we describe a consensus as something not
merely that most scientists generally
agree on,
although that's often true.
What scientific consensus really means
is that this is research that has been
repeated in other labs and the results
have been confirmed.
The results have been scrutinized.
People have tried to disprove them.
People tried to find alternate
explanations and it has truly past a
certain level of scientific rigor.
Then we say we have a scIentific
consensus in science circles.
Consensus means a lot more than it does
in popular usage and you will find that
the consensus is that supplementation
has no benefit among healthy people who
don't have a deficiency due to some
strange cars,
whatever that might be.
I think you will always find articles to
the contrary or articles like this that
sensationalize that into something that
it's not
sensationalize the the negative aspects
of it.
I don't think there's really a consensus
about a supplementation because in order
to really totally,
completely monitor like the variations
between two human beings,
you'd have to have two people that were
exactly the same genetically exactly the
same as far as their life experiences,
their life stress,
all the different factors that add up to
health.
There is a massive range of factors that
come into play when you're dealing with
a person's health.
If you measure a bunch of people with
very good diets,
rich in green leafy vegetables and live
foods and all these different healthy
things and no bullshit and processed
foods,
and then you measure people who have the
typical american fast food dine,
I think you're going to see that these
nutrients is certainly beneficial to the
people that eat healthy food are
certainly going to have a,
a greater instance of,
uh,
of being healthy but to,
to to really break it down and figure
out how much of an effect a nutritional
supplement would have based on based on
that would be like you'd have to take
the exact same people live in the exact
same lives and one of them would take a
supplement and one of them wouldn't me
be really hard to figure out and then
you'd have to say,
well,
if you eat healthy,
it's the best way.
Everybody agrees on that.
I don't think I've heard a single person
who knows about health and nutrition
that says that you could eat shitty food
and just take vitamins.
It's impossible.
It doesn't work that way.
You.
There's certain aspects of food that's
just missing in pill form.
You're always better off getting fresh
leafy vegetables that are right out of
the ground,
but taking supplements as well with a
very diet,
especially if your diet doesn't balance
out as long as we're aware of the
bioavailability,
those supplements,
and then we're also aware that your body
can absorb some of those supplements.
It seems to me like you're hedging your
bets.
It seems like it's a good idea to take a
good,
strong natural food based.
I'm a supplementation program.
Uh,
I think generally there's no harm in
them,
no harm and no,
I can say except for the wallet right
there,
just unnecessary.
I don't know if they're unnecessary.
If your diet is not totally balanced.
Well makeup,
but I think it maybe they'll make up
some slack and if it can make up some
slack than I think that is a,
that the beneficial.
I think if you have a healthy diet,
you're right,
you don't need it,
but there's a lot of shit that you get
from from vitamin supplementation like
like there's certain like five htp,
like five htp which produces serotonin.
If you're,
if you're trying to get that from food,
you gotta eat like a fucking garbage bag
full of grass,
you know,
you're,
you're not going to the amount that you
can take in a couple of pills.
The extracted form of the,
the,
the active nutrients like fuck.
You'd have to eat a lot of stuff to get
that and I think that that science,
these people have figured out how to
extract these things.
They're not just guessing.
They're not just guessing what the
effects are on the body or guessing how
to get this stuff out of food or what.
What contains it.
They know,
and that is science as well.
It always amazes me how the human race
managed to survive until this decade
before all these things were invented.
We survived,
but that's not the idea.
The idea is,
are we,
are we optimized?
And manY times,
no,
many times we're not optimized.
We're optimized when we add supplements,
sometimes you know,
sometimes supplements can if you were in
a situation where you're not getting all
the beneficial nutrients,
but you add them and then try to balance
out your diet as well.
I think it can.
It can aid you.
I don't think it's an either or.
I think undeniably healthy food is the
number one thing for for health healthy
food.
Your body is what I was talking to these
hunters yesterday and they were talking
about how bears that eat certain foods
are not good to eat.
Like if bears eat rotten fish and eat
them,
like you literally taste the rotten
fish,
but if bears eat blueberries,
they're delicious and they're there.
They actually had a hunting episode
about catching a bears,
blueberry bears that come out of the
dens and just feast on these huge hills
of blueberries and they get fat with.
With blueberry fat.
It's amazing because as they're cutting
this fat off,
it's like a bluish fat,
like the dye from the blueberry actually
makes it into their cells.
Unbelievable.
But it stands to reason that we are also
what we eat and if we eat a ton of
healthy foods that our flesh is enriched
with nutrients are,
our tissue is enriched with this,
this purified water and these healthy
vegetables and good lean proteins and
all these different things that are good
for us.
If you could take that,
a little bit of that in pill form as
well.
I don't think it's a bad thing for you.
Like I say,
I agree.
It's not a bad thing for you.
It's just,
it's just almost always unnecessary.
And so if you want to lead a super
balanced diet,
I think if you have any kind of,
uh,
any kind of a diet and if you don't live
in,
you know,
chat or Somalia,
you're getting your,
you're doing pretty well.
So you think that it's not worth it.
Your call is that it's not worth it.
Like the amount of money spent on
providing men's is pretty expensive.
Huge.
Yeah.
If tremendous.
And multivitamins,
if you're going to buy the.
I buy these packs,
these men pure packs,
these athlete pure packs because it's
easy for me to do and I think they're
called,
I forget what it costs.
It's probably like a dollar,
a pill pack or something like that.
Maybe maybe a little bit more and over
time.
yeah,
that could,
uh,
that could add up.
But for me,
I think of it as a hedging my bet.
I want to make sure I get as much
nutrients in my body as I can.
You know,
there's a lot,
there's a lot more substantial things to
worry about in life.
There's also things though that the
average person doesn't need that
athletes do.
And I think that that's a,
that's another issue when it comes to
supplementation.
Athletes,
a lot of benefit in food and
supplementation now can't always have
more fluid depending on what you're in.
You know,
some,
some athletes have to watch their weight
gotta wash the girlish figure,
so they just need to make sure they get
some exercise to brian,
you and I agree on more than we disagree
or not.
I,
I'm sorry if I was rough with you about
certain things like defending my friend
mark,
but if I didn't you would've fucking
killed me next time I saw him and I
would have to deal with glutosiome and
talk for an hour and a half.
I just want to review the tweets and how
many people have called me an asshole
over the.
Oh,
he can't listen if anybody's calling
brian and asshole.
He's not an asshole.
And I think that your ideas essentially
the,
the hard stance that you take is
because,
you know,
there's so much bullshit out there and I
think it's a good stance.
I think it's the right stance most of
the time.
And I think that,
you know,
by,
by being this hard edge,
no nonsense guide though it does
eliminate some of the flexibility of
this world.
The,
the real conspiracies are automatically
dismissed for the standard,
you know,
official report.
No,
I think that's not always good either,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean the old saying extraordinary
claims need extraordinary evidence.
Sure.
If you go around and questioning,
you know whether this table is real or
whether it's an illusion,
obviously that's silly,
but you got to draw the line somewhere.
I don't know.
I had dr mikhal,
swami theoretical physicist,
and he made me question everything.
I started talking about string theory
and the fucking particles in the state
of superposition where they're moving
and still at the same time they appear
and denny's a swami.
Well,
his name is dr.
goswami.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I don't get on racist dude.
Happens to be indian.
They'll come down on you hard son.
There's a billion of them.
I want to thank you for coming on the
podcast first fall and I want to thank
you for just discussing all this stuff.
Maybe it's,
it's.
It's fascinating and like I said,
I think we agree more than we disagree
and I'm glad we cleared up.
Hopefully some of the misconceptions
about how I approach things because I
certainly am easy to criticize and I'm
certainly easy to categorize as well.
It's a lot of my ridiculous comments,
aren't we all on various things have
suggested.
Well,
I will certainly be following this up on
[inaudible] dot com.
What does that mean?
The battle continues.
That's sounds like a warning man.
Battle commodities is a little bit of a
battle.
Thank you very much and people can find
you on twitter.
It's brian dunning on twitter.
Brian with an I and d u n n I n g dot
and skeptical is a podcast.
Please download and subscribe to that
and anything else people should go to to
check it out.
Go to the.
Check me out.
I mean,
you know your stuff,
you know,
inflammation.
Tinder.
What do you want to say before we wrap
this pitch up?
I'm on facebook,
but it's very unfortunate.
Page name is tom dunning fan page.
The fan page humiliates the hell out of
it.
Did you enjoy this conversation or was
it frustrated?
I had a great time.
Okay,
good.
Thank you.
I feel it makes me feel much better.
I hate when people leave here in the
men.
Don't want anybody mad.
I think,
uh,
I would love to do this again.
We'll talk again and maybe we can
address some of the things that people
said online and the main things are
going to call you and me.
We're gonna.
Have some fun.
All right.
Thank you everybody.
Thanks for tuning into the podcast.
We'll be back friday with the one and
only steven rinella.
Uh,
who,
uh,
is taken me pig hunting this weekend,
sir.
I can't wait.
I'm very excited.
Um,
and uh,
as far as dates to morrow,
uh,
it is going live on twitter.
I'm going to be in dallas,
uh,
at the verizon theater and uh,
that is in march,
I think.
March.
Hold on a second.
March 14th.
Friday at 10.
No,
no,
no.
Presales tomorrow.
Friday am is a regular sale,
but tomorrow the presale is at 10:00 AM.
And the,
a ticket a password is first.
So if you type in the word first,
uh,
you,
you can buy tickets tomorrow and it's at
the verizon theater.
I don't know who'S coming with me.
I'm putting it all together right now.
Um,
and that's it.
Anything else?
Uh,
oh,
uh,
chicago were at the chicago theater on
January 24th.
It's me and the renegade jew ari fear,
that's his new nickname called him that
from now on,
I want,
my goal is to haVe the tsa meet him and
go,
oh,
so renegade jew,
Come on through sir.
Immediately recognize that he's,
he's silly man.
You don't have to frisk him.
He's not blowing anything up.
So that's january 20,
first at 24th rather at the chicago
theater.
And that's it.
Thank you to our sponsors.
Thank you to squarespace to enter into
the squarespace competition.
Go to a hashtag,
put this up on twitter.
Hashtag j r,
e squarespace.
And by this friday the a.
or is this saturday the 17th?
What's the 17,
four,
five,
six.
17th is a friday or saturday.
It's friday.
This friday we're going to decide the
winters.
So,
um,
I will,
that will,
this friday is the last day to send them
in and I'll decide the winter's over the
weekend and I will give away for free
years to,
uh,
to squarespace for different people.
Will get a free year.
And also,
uh,
I will give away a higher primate tee
shirt to all four winters as well.
And in squarespace has a bunch of other
swag that goes along with that,
with the other one today.
And ting is one of our all time
favorite.
Legal zoom will take two.
Let's give it a little love tank,
brogan.ting.com.
Cell phone sign.
And legal zoom.
Of course,
legal zoom is one of our favorite
sponsors because brian has used it on it
was formed with legal zoom.
It is something that we,
we absolutely believe in an awesome way
to deal with a lot of legal issues that
are otherwise very difficult and costly.
Go to legal zoom.com and enter rogan in
the referral box at checkout for more
savings.
And go to onnit o n n I t use the
codeword rogan and save 10 percent off
any and all supplements.
Much love you.
Super freaks.
And,
uh,
we'll see you on friday.
Big kiss.